pulled up to Calabasas Ready for War I
might turn to a Savage I just showed up
with the crew the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice uh you going down for the count
it's going down tonight I do it all for
my family you do it all for the likes I
hear that Bell and I'm ready to fight
Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up they
want the boat they don't work and no
don't mess around and end up hurting
them I say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing I might
hurt we are live what is up fam is a
very special edition of the Calabasas
fight companion and we are in cahoots
with rough and rowdy 19 season beatings
Barstool Sports welcome to the broadcast
I put together a very very special
lineup to the left he is first team
Mount Rushmore UFC Legend Rampage
Jackson Mount Rushmore no no no no no no
no no you'd be the only black guy on
there but it's a big deal it's a big
deal and then next to him another Legend
another Legend a man I've known for a
hot second and this dude is bodied up
now and he looks fantastic it is the
walking legend himself Donald Cerrone
minus the lies I just come right out and
say I wanted to do this [ __ ] yeah hey I
didn't know if he was going to do that
on camera too I thought we might weren't
supposed to talk about what he was
talking about oh no cowboys yeah he's
not fighting you saw to bring it on yeah
and then directly to my right this man
is an entertainment Mogul he is the P
Diddy uh freaking podcast and he does it
all no jumper plug talk you do it all my
man it is adam22. what's up brother how
you doing shop
Cowboy I'm excited to be here I heard he
goes wrong oh yeah oh yeah and I've seen
it very wrong oh you checked it out oh
yeah you gotta see what you're working
with dude before I had you on the show
I'm glad to hear that yeah I'm impressed
you signed up for the only fans oh yeah
I mean yeah support my boy I'm not gay
we gotta support my boy well I have the
fighter and the kid patreon for the same
reason
yeah yeah but it's just me and Brian I
haven't opened it up yet it's just me
and an old guy yeah it's Milford yeah
but this is uh this is a different uh
fight Japan I've ever done because this
isn't High Caliber UFC fighting you know
this is rough and rowdy it's
entertaining but you know you got a guy
named trapzilla he's a male stripper and
he's trapped up man he looks like Vito
who's that in the middle right there
that's Dave Portnoy the the owner of uh
Barstool Sports and then big cat to the
right and then Robbie is on the left I
know Robbie for freaking ever where's
Ronda Rowdy I I thought the shoes
they need to have that but yeah so the
fights will be like you know I was
watching I've been a fan for a while
some you know they get a little dicey
now you do have Pac-Man Jones fighting
if you remember him from uh the Dallas
Cowboys Pac-Man Jones is fighting a a
tough character where is this this is in
Providence Rhode Island look it's sold
out oh yeah these things crazy have you
ever been to Rhode Island ain't [ __ ] to
do there Providence is actually pretty
lit but yeah there's not much to do
besides comedy connection and then go to
Newport and explore all those yeah
oh you've been there yeah I've been
there yeah I grew up an hour and a half
from Providence oh did you really I'm
sure yeah you're from New Hampshire yeah
wow somebody's out there you're a New
York cat no you sell this yeah this is
Pay-per-view yeah but it's Ikea how much
is it Jen is it it's like 14.99 or 29.99
it's not it's not like UFC pricing you
know they but it's a good product it's
our school fan base is insane insane
they are ready to consume but and and it
it works with my fan base because the
real cockfest on both ends 29.95 what is
it 29.95 I'm not a bad dealership you
know for a nice little night for a nap
yeah they they got the thing going on
they have the ring girl competition they
do all sorts of stuff right is that for
the restroom or for sex
I was just wondering the same thing I
think you just wipe anything on the dude
you want with it but would you use it
like after sex like you clean up real
quick you could you could wipe your
baby's ass with a baby wipe I feel like
it's like based on the name I think that
it's that but for grown men oh you think
it's for the restroom that's what's what
I'm assuming yeah I think it's for the
restroom I think it's for anything right
like if you're if you kind of smell you
put on your armpits oh it's mint chill I
don't know I feel bad about like I don't
know if you want to rub that I don't
know if you want to rub that on the
wanker because then it's got a little
minty yeah the girls might like it
though as long as there's no alcohol on
it right that's what I mean I'm worried
about like the Cool Breeze oh no there
you go you're right we hated using
toilet paper so we created the flushable
dude wipes wet wipes specifically for
cleaning your butt and dude regions
which would include your wiener no
that's good I would most definitely use
that because have you guys ever I have a
Japanese toilet but whenever you travel
and you go without a Japanese toilet
like you you what do you mean Japanese
toilet you know
oh yeah bidet yeah you got hooked on
that yeah man I can't I can't I can't
use the toilet without it I'm a fan
manual world right now I'm a fan too I
don't have one but the electric one oh
oh my Lord it just got a lot more
talented in here
how you doing man
doing all right yeah many huge fans of
the whole game you didn't get the memo
five o'clock he didn't get the memo LA
traffic traffic or something
on you
bro pipes yeah let me introduce the man
who just got it he's pouring himself
tequila right away it is the voice of an
Angel
you've never heard this gentleman sing
you are missing out it is Teddy swims
and he is the most talented bastard on
the planet he's an angel with tattoos on
his face oh yeah I get I get uh drawn
into the uh to listen just going through
your videos like oh yeah another one
another one oh bro
he covered uh uh Journeys Don't Stop
Believing on the piano when he was
singing this to the piano so I start my
days all right you got 83 million views
on a Mario cover oh bro oh no jeez well
hey that's YouTube as well that was the
first thing that came up but you know
and I spoke to Jelly Roll right before
you got here until he swims I was
speaking of jelly driving in here
Jelly's performing tonight some sold out
he's doing Arena straight Arena
yeah yeah that's right he's doing some
Arena out there he's like you tell Teddy
I love him come out there and do a
companion with both of you he's crushing
he said he wishes you were there he's
like you teddy should have been with me
man performing tonight instead of the
companion I said sure you should have
told him man I'm sure he'd rather be
doing that than this you know okay so
what did I miss enough about nothing
we were just talking about
introducing the empty chair was there
and then you came sprinting yeah you're
only about two minutes so how do we feel
about dude wives it gets the job done
for you we're trying to decide what
exactly I've never used a dude why but I
did use the bidets we were talking about
Rampage has a bidet yeah
hunting and brought baby wipes with you
is there a difference between dude wipes
and baby wipes or is it just like a
toxic masculinity thing and they just
browned it they just Brown branded too
yeah it's like liquid death it's like
water I totally put a baby
I understand you know I can understand
it though because you don't want to be
wiping your ass with baby wipes if
you're a man exactly yeah
well that's the culture it's like yeah
I don't care especially when I'm in the
toilet you know nobody knows what I'm
wiping my ass that's my spot for me
it's got a little fart in it the one
that's gonna itch later yeah
that makes sense hey I'm so green to
this and I'm still excited when the ring
girls come out
oh but no everyone should be green I
mean you know they've had 19 of them
it's not like the UFC like yeah they do
a ring girl contest that's big cats
singing like it's it's a bar stool event
man this looks like a white power rally
Here Comes Hulk of mania
it's not even Halloween
it's not Halloween dude that's
Providence Rhode Island no that's the
real Macho Man Okay number four okay
number four
the UFC would never allow this but we're
gonna show the first three fights in the
picture in picture so you guys can watch
along with us and then you're gonna
watch the rest of it go buy the the
pay-per-view at uh buyrnr.com yeah so
you can watch the first three fights
with us it's gonna be chaos yo but I
gotta try one of those I saw you I saw
you bragging real hard on those Rogues
yeah yeah you got it what do you got in
right now oh no no these destroys
chewing a Zan no no no
no no come here
yeah I like six or just one yeah you can
put a real true in apple pouch I'm not
ready for that world you know so much
they like made so much of my guns like
the real chew because I preferred my
little corners and they got so receded
right here in that bad boy from where I
used to dip all the time and uh the
twins really saved my life but yeah I
saw the other day you you know wrapped
it up man love them love them I like to
find out for myself yeah I like like
they're on the bottom uh well I would
wear I would wear my top ones too but I
also didn't want to if we're gonna be on
a mic I get a little bit of a list but I
don't want somebody listening and and I
was like and I don't want to flex too
hard like I got a whole mouthful of
diamonds and I'm just lifting through
this mic right now just to look cool in
front of you guys I don't want to you
don't want to look too cool in front of
you guys but I definitely wanted to be
cool yeah you want to flex too hard but
also it's cool yeah you know it's it's
not it's not too much if I wasn't 44 I
think I'd do I've been thinking about
getting another thing oh you can put
your brand page bro there's no but I'm
44 now man there's no age doesn't matter
when you're the fan page it don't matter
no not for you
could be twice you got nice teas and
good bone structure nice looking bed you
know you should you should I should
bring more attention I'm gonna go the
other way I don't think it's 44 too old
you're not a Soulja Boy anymore you're
not getting a motorcycle you were never
a soldier boy no never you think you
missed your Soulja Boy era yeah I missed
that you didn't know you're a Soulja Boy
when you were no I I never Superman a
hole or nothing like that but Soulja Boy
never got enough credit right like he
put He did a lot of stuff yeah plenty of
credit is just that like he kind of got
left in the in the Dust by like a
million other rappers and he's his main
way of like going viral is by reminding
everybody that yeah I did all this [ __ ]
back in 2006 or whatever and it's like
all right before the internet was yeah
yeah he was like one of the first
internet right and didn't he say Drake
stole like his like way of rapping or
something he said Drake stole everything
he said everybody stole everything from
him and it was that's like his thing
have you had him on the show yeah was he
cool before all this yeah oh wow he
hates me now you had him and you you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] on the show no no I
mean maybe I don't know not like his
name but maybe one of his [ __ ] it's a
high probability that you guys crossed
your Eskimo brothers
yeah dude yeah did you Superman his hope
not that I know him but yeah but he's
probably had many hoes yes correct yeah
you know
we had the first fight starting right
now this dude came out and uh what is
that mass what is that chin is that
skeleton
okay I can't tell okay so what what
exactly is this man Ruffin Rowdy again
fighting oh yeah it's like the I was
watching one from uh I think it was
rough around 85 it was a a lady from uh
a nice handsome lady from West Virginia
with no teeth finding a 19 year old girl
with uh she was a wrestler and this this
girl's beat the [ __ ] out of her this is
the Black Joker kids trucks and do you
have to wear the uh Kitty pad or no
that's just preference well see that's
because it's in Providence Rhode Island
so I'm wondering because they're oh no a
lot of them don't have any experience so
as far as the commission goes I assume
they get away with some stuff because if
it it was if it was straight amateur
Cowboy they'd have to wear headgear
right I yeah because I had when I did
Golden Gloves I had to wear a head kid
right there was commissions I'm not sure
on the commission here You Gotta Wear
the tank top too yeah yeah so is this
like a minor league kind of situation
where they're kind of just getting their
feet wet to get into the no I don't
think these people have aspirations to
go you know like GoPro it's more of just
like a fun event like Barstool was like
hey let's put this event on they own the
they bought the the organization and
they they build it up they have
something I don't got the you got the
cheetah print or the uh Black Joker I
got black joker I'm going cheetah print
that's what I'm saying the kidney is for
the kidneys they should wear it up under
their shorts who who nah that's how the
boxes are the big ass diaper but this is
like influencer boxing but for people
who don't have any influence but for
some reason the Barstool fans care about
them for some reason yeah well they'll
put some of their talent on like they
put some of the female ladies that they
work with and some other people on there
and they'll build the highway
they're their own they're the NFL
pre-fight content you know like they
have all their own shoes oh look he's
got the Batman logo on his chest too
what a guy see that's Joker versus
Batman and then I'm pretty sure the
rounds are only a minute longer real
good usually really high yeah one minute
rounds uh black joke in second round
female ref
uh I'm the homeboy with the no shirt and
the yeah they're moving the braids is
yeah he's not bad yeah he's moving like
he knows he's oh now they are five five
but the focus on Black Joker right there
man is that not let anything really
affect him he just kind of keeps his
ground which is the Under Armor tank gun
and the cutoff sweatshirt was doing it
oh it's oh you're right the capris
it's gonna get weirder as these fights
go on gentlemen sometimes there's two
small people going at it last time I
watched I'm ready for that oh that was
fantastic
so how many how many flights is they all
together yeah there's a lot uh there's a
good amount you're gonna you're gonna
Teddy you're gonna see some [ __ ] tonight
my man
we got some time to get some time to
kill now you're in La for a while
brother you came out here originally for
what um
a couple days the talk okay yeah a
little daytime
well oh damn the The Joker he got a
knock down
man
well then yeah yeah yeah
you get it you'd have to get a grill
mouthpiece you know what I mean like
that would actually be gangster a little
like a little ice in the grill someone's
done that before though who did that in
the UFC someone did that it was like the
fangs with the silver yeah it looked
like a grill a free who did this what's
that Russian guy's name
he had the fangs but no he didn't do
like the grill oh got that tall ring
girl
wet [ __ ] outfit than a UFC ring girl
she doesn't like Marilyn Manson like I
told you this isn't UFC they're allowed
to get a little more risque yeah
oh yeah I like tall and thin girls
though I like that really yeah but but
only if they're uh Japanese right no no
I like all girls I know but Japanese and
I like all ice cream but I have a
preference right yeah yeah so he's
asking Robin got 31 Flavors and every
time I get vanilla
[Music]
you apply that to so many things in my
life man yeah you never mix it up
bro I haven't dated an Asian girl in a
while really yeah that used to be your
thing though and you learned huh man you
know what that how come I did right now
they it's just oh they're hot yeah yeah
yeah the endemic [ __ ] it up they
[ __ ] it up yeah I commodity everybody
want Asian now I wonder what did that
BTS man
oh there's Pac-Man Jones he's the main
event
is he oh no
I think he's won an all right Jim but he
got well he's definitely want to know
he's only one on this but he's 1-0 on
the streets because I saw him beat up a
TSA Employee at uh how do you know
Pac-Man he look like future huh yeah he
kind of does yeah
so how did how did that you're gonna owe
me half your wrench how have you have
you got very little experience like in
your 0-1 how does that make you the the
main event I think you have to have like
a little bit you know again this is It's
a far cry earn your way to that main
event yeah but it's more like uh Pac-Man
he's obviously athletic like he was a
first team
that dude's done at this level that
dude's done they need to stop the fight
oh yeah stay down so I can so I can win
yeah she's like you ready he's like nah
I'm gang you know how dumb that Batman
logo looks right now
did I not call it yeah Rampage want to
know I'mma win one the dude who looks
super serious got his ass beat by the
guy
that's always how it happens yeah yeah
it looks like Tyler the Creator
yeah that is good yes yeah they should
be friends it's not come on it's not
that serious
hey I gotta say man I like this whiskey
thanks brother tiger thick tiger thick
and I can get it from the liquor store
yeah it's already in there oh yeah oh is
that your thing yeah yes sir you're a
Tequila man though huh well I see I was
a big big bourbon man and then um as I
as I've been touring a lot I've found
that it's giving me some heartburn and
messes with my little uh I get a little
heartburn from now my sweet little
things so I just kind of switched to
tequila and then I really started
developing a real taste I like tequila
too man I mean I usually only drink
whiskey and then did jelly roll his
doctors like hey man if you don't stop
drinking like I'll probably do a jelly
roll in uh Shreveport nothing like it
you've never seen a human being drink
more in your life I do I'm telling you
man
me too I can't no no one can drink that
much chin went with him to because jelly
rolls torn here I think he's doing like
Staple Center some [ __ ] he's some
crazy Arena
dude bro he didn't slow down but he only
drinks somehow he got in his head some
doctor some weird doctor was like now
you can drink but only tequila so he
thinks it's healthy he's drinking
tequila so he only drinks tequila that's
why I thought maybe jelly roll like
influenced you on that but you never
seen a human drink the human being drink
more in your life chin went with him to
the Honda Center you have the video of
you hanging out with them watch chin
faded get off the tour bus white girl
wasted stomping around well and then
racing smoking too so that's a little
super [ __ ] you up when you mix that if
you're not a professional yes yeah I
can't be mixing and matching like that
one or the other so there's jelly he
gets off right
this is after the show chin this is
after the show yeah
oh you'll never see him drunk you can't
even tell
and then chin comes out hot wobbly
and then there's me
did you lose your virginity that night
pretty much I don't usually smoke but I
smoked with them yeah so then I was just
like
um
the other concert yeah
yeah he's a monster of a man and I don't
know how he I just I know his heart's
got to be working overtime I know are
you familiar with the Jelly Roll hit pop
another pill with a little white no oh
that's a very different era of his
career that I remember fondly yeah
there's CMA Awards jelly got big because
he he was in prison he would rap he
would rap in prison to entertain himself
then he got out and one of his buddies
right when he got out filmed him just
freestyling and it blew up oh so you're
a musician yeah oh man go to YouTube and
search pop another pill and let me pop
it out we can't actually play it on
there yeah yeah but just let me like
grab like a screenshot of what he looked
like in the early part of his career
yeah yeah the flag yeah YouTubes
brother I'm not gonna lie when you got
the interview with him I was just like
what the [ __ ] cause me and him about
doing it forever
okay look at this this is the era that I
remember bro wow yeah and he was boys
like Bubba Sparks like he comes from
that you know
white he's basically like one walking
talking Xanax
right uh I forget honestly but he was
with uh three and six miles yeah and
everything back in the day Three Six
Mafia had a white guy yeah yeah wow
good for him man I never really went
anywhere but yeah I'm still out here
doing it
yeah look at jelly back in the day
that's fresh but then to see jelly roll
have this whole another like round of
his career gnarly right yeah
massive country hit and a massive Rock
ain't that like number one on rock radio
like yeah blowing up on country radio
selling out Arenas like jellies he's
just having I mean that's just the power
of like apparently it's just so good to
see good people just like he's like
man I'm so proud of you man oh he's the
best guy
yeah he's the biggest person out of the
biggest heart no he's in he's in
Nashville and he's held me down man him
and uh you know he's real close with
struggle Jennings man they uh I think I
had like when I first started Teddy
swims I think I had like maybe 2 000
followers on Instagram or something and
I just did like my first cover and he'd
him and struggle reached out to me and
had had my back like I mean I can't tell
you how much jelly would he's such a
good dude he's the one who was doing
he's talking about you I was like cool
and he's like take swims yeah I've never
had a bigger cheerleader than oh he's
the best person
yeah you haven't had jelly on the show
Adam no I'm still trying
he'll come out here yeah he loves you he
was trying to last time I went to
Nashville for a week over the summer he
was he was here while I was there
correct because he's here doing uh I
think Jimmy uh Fallon all the best fried
chicken I ever had my whole life was a
natural yeah
the other day somebody tried to tell me
that La has a better Fried Chicken
have you had Helen raised though I
haven't had like 10 spots in Nashville
that were better than it no or like on
that level for sure
Fried Chicken is just not really have
you had Helen raised barbecue is not
having it out here right yeah
Georgia are you from Joel dogs Atlanta
Georgia man and you're a bulldog fan
yeah dude we just good dude we just we
just got to go uh to the SEC
Championship
I got to go like go oh you said you went
oh damn so when we were on when we were
on the road man I've uh I've had this
opportunity man like about two years ago
uh Dominique Wilkins Amanda
Legend man you hit me up on Instagram
it's like hey man I want you to come
play my uh my my birthday party and so
since like so I went and played his
birthday party in January of like a
couple years ago and
um that's where you know that's where
that's that's where I met uh so I do all
of Dominic's events he's one of my best
friends and best will you ever meet like
man and uh so I met this guy Josh Brooks
who was uh he's the uh
he's athletic director of Georgia and so
um like we ended up becoming really
close and now he's just like dude we got
to go see the SEC Championship got in
his box because it was in Atlanta right
yeah
oh man I got to go uh when we just ended
our tour in Athens I got to go do like a
whole tour of the Athletic Facility it's
nuts man there's not a weight in the
Georgia play there's not a weight that
doesn't have a g on it I mean the
elevator button has a g on it it's dude
it's like a I mean best he said it best
80 million dollars can buy you yeah it's
like cheese
I don't know who's going to beat the
Georgia Bulldogs either we're going to
win this year and we're going to win
next year now listen my CU Buffs where I
played the one in 11 this year it's a
sad time but we did just get Deion
Sanders as the head coach
we should we should do next time we do
one live yeah do one of these live we
sit there
yeah I'm down to go Pizza yeah her
office says pizza that's like a Barstool
inside joke that I don't get right which
one I don't know Pizza just it feels
like a joke
has the pizza show right just pizza [ __ ]
I don't know if you tried somewhere okay
yeah you tried somewhere today in uh
Providence some pizza joint all right
mm-hmm
these boys are tired even though they're
one minute rounds if you're not trained
a minute's forever yeah
the pace oh yeah I'm telling you wait
till you see the main event that this
this page couldn't do a minute right now
[ __ ] I could do a minute you do a minute
I could do a minute right exactly one
minute yeah I can do a minute I just I
didn't know if anybody if I I could do
it I would last a minute with you but I
would yeah I definitely wouldn't I
definitely got two faces
bro the way Cowboy looks you know you
ain't gotta you gotta run faster than me
then in your Vine Cowboy beat up this
entire building
this dude is jacked dude I want in
cowboy Oh man I've done that liver King
diet dog and I want in I got the goods
man deliver straight to the old door
dude I was saying Cowboy can you imagine
your money back double can you imagine
being in this physical shape and then
fighting the Octagon I uh I was just
literally yesterday in Vegas and I was
telling everybody like I I understand
why
steroids are illegal yeah yeah I it now
that I'm injecting them into my body and
I feel like I'm [ __ ] 20 again Cowboy
undefeated oh man you just you the
training would never stop you could just
literally train as hard as you wanted to
wake up the next day covered and fresh
you trained like a crazed man as it is
Imagine at this level and then your your
punches your kicks your Cardio Recovery
recovery recovery
oh yeah it's the founding youth but what
what year did the UFC start to like
crack down on the stairs because I feel
like when I watch a lot of those fights
everybody looks [ __ ] cute huge During
certain eras you know especially like
well especially when the three of us
fought in the UFC it wasn't that strict
and then usada came along in 2015.
that's when it got dicey when you saw it
came it was like super strict but before
2015 they're going out trt exemptions
you know you got Brock Lesnar over him
like when Alistair fought when Alistair
fought Brock I mean you've never seen
him more he could have finished third in
Mr Olympia or you mean the uh the eating
the horse meat yeah yeah that boy guess
what though where I come from fighting
in Japan they didn't test for it I was
just watching Kevin Randleman and I'm
like look at this like you have not seen
a guy with a body like this in the UFC
or anything since this era that's what
they still say about Rampage you've
never seen a person with a body like
well yeah you kind of look a little bit
like that too sure
people I used to fight in UFC they said
what KFC
[ __ ] you laughing
we both heavyweights all right now and
that's what yeah yeah like I like that I
like that yeah because in Pride like uh
who was it I think it might have been
Chuck Liddell I forget who was telling
me they said in the contract it was like
we in capital like all caps black like
we do not yeah that's the first that was
the first thing
like to get on some [ __ ] they like
Monsters but they test but they test for
like cocaine and marijuana
he's drug testing me every time and and
I always made it a point that when they
drug tested me I always fill up the the
cups all the way to the rim I'll be
spilling piss all over so they gotta
grab it yeah can they test with drugs
but they won't test with steroids and
I've never done steroids I've done I've
done testosterone but I've never done
but I've never done it while I was
fighting in the UFC yeah when it was
illegal I did it for a little bit but
then uh who's that that [ __ ] it up for
everybody what was his name my card no
he got in trouble because they was I
know detour messed it up but then also
uh what's his name I don't know the
Russian cat no I fought him the uh one
of the talks a lot I fought him in
Bellator
he [ __ ] it up for everybody because he
he went he took his levels too high but
that's what happened with Nate too on a
card I was fighting on he's supposed to
fight Dan Miller and he had a trt
exemption and then they tested him he's
14 times over the level he's supposed to
be at and they're like what are you
doing though yeah give me an hour give
me an hour after I lost to Jon Jones I I
went and got my test uh my test
um you know test yeah the blood yeah and
my [ __ ] was low as [ __ ] I was like what
the [ __ ] how was my [ __ ] most guys are
too if you're doing training like from a
young age like all your adrenal glands
are you don't realize how [ __ ]
especially as much as you trained in all
the fights like yeah I don't know I had
no idea and the lady the lady of like
she tested mine she said you've been on
steroids before I'm like no I haven't
she said the only way you get this low
test if you've been on steroid I said
look her later that's not true if if
you've been at a young age competing at
in Combat Sports that'll do it that'll
just Destroyer every time you use your
adrenaline yeah
yeah you play football young which check
I did then if you you know played
football for a while check and then
fighting check you know so I would say
steroids yeah I agree that steroids
should be illegal for um fighting and
stuff but it's so fun though if you if
you if you keep it at a like 800 or
something like that I think that should
be the playing field I don't think they
should make that illegal the thing of
that stuff if you go down that route
some people are naturally like I got a
boy his natural levels and he's 44 mid
40s his natural levels are like 1200.
Brittany Greiner probably got more
testosterone than Cowboy right now 100
is that is that a man
no
are you serious you will not she will
she will dunk in your face though
Brittany Greiner she's the one she's the
one the United States trade for the
death of arms dealer the Russian arms
dealers
I'm believing the media narrative on
this one straight up if we're like I
don't know a lot about
that but I know about trading and we got
when you get [ __ ] you get [ __ ] if
that was a bat we got oh that was bad
trade you're telling me we're gonna give
you this I mean horrible you know
criminal you know war criminal and you
give us a w WNBA player you know that's
the deal yeah that was yeah that's the
yeah is that where they ended up on that
yeah and you couldn't get the the
veteran out now I'm glad she's back
because she's American so thank God
she's back but also we can't get a two
for one but then the death of arms they
said the veteran or what was his name I
forget but they said he was off the
table like Russia wasn't willing to part
with him look at that oh damn he got
dropped
you think he's not yeah I don't know if
he is let me know what he's taking
they're not testing in in absolutely
because I've seen some fights where math
would they would they get you on the
meth yeah they did one what the [ __ ] he
didn't know anything they did one fight
in West Virginia everybody testing but
yo do you think that when they do the
influencer boxing matches do you think
all of those are tested or just like
some of them someone know Jake Paul test
the the big one the big one because the
commission is going to want that
Mike that that dude is who this matchup
oh he pushed him there that's not really
a knockdown yeah he fell he pushed him
that dude's hair makes it look worse
he's that young Bieber cut it's all
flopping around that used to be
kickboxing
yeah yeah
man if he thought was supposed to fight
hunting he backed out he was supposed to
fight uh who's he supposed to fight you
oh Rock him uh Rocky and Junior oh that
guy sucked yeah he's bad Brockman
Rockman yeah that guy sucked yeah he's
supposed to fight him and then he pulled
out and then who stepped in for uh
Rockman Junior chin
um Greg Hardy Greg Hardy yeah
Greg Hardy you know Greg Hardy has to
cut the 265 when he's in the UFC he
fought that fight he was like 288 or
something a big boy yeah yeah I heard
people don't realize how athletic he is
either he's all pro defense event for
Carolina Panthers yeah I don't know what
they're signing up for yeah he's a big
boy big boy he just got started too late
there's not enough hours in the day to
make up for experience yeah see
especially at heavy weight the
heavyweight's big now but he kicked
rocking his ass on that boy hits hard
you know they they um wanted me to take
that fight last minute I was on my way
to Thailand that day
are you gonna beat him
you yeah but I was but I was I would
have took the flight I would took the
fight but I had to catch a flight that
day yeah
I'm surprised some of those Russian
organizations haven't offered you some
some wild [ __ ] they do like medieval
fighting out there and [ __ ] no no I
haven't got I haven't gotten into office
the only person trying to fight me is
that that same God Shannon Briggs oh
yeah let's go champ
I'm down to do it but uh it's like um
ain't nobody nobody want to see the
fight but this is what I heard I heard
that he's backed out a lot of fights so
people don't believe that he's really
gonna fight
oh really no no he's bigger than me oh
damn
I know you are yeah and cowboy how do
you feel about like the the Jake Paul's
of the world that fighting you cool with
it like I don't know I'm surprised Jake
Paul hasn't come after you now you're
retired
um like that's what he does yeah he goes
for the superstars like you versus Jake
that's exactly what he did a big fight
well you guys are out there asking about
it back in the back I said they're
asking me how I felt about it and I was
like man I I think the dudes
legitimately has to have boxing correct
right like yeah those punches they like
especially with Anderson like timing and
everything yeah man yeah that's not just
he's got power and those legitimate
punches those guys aren't first of all
Anderson wouldn't
like Ben came out and was like for
people that think it's fake he's like
listen I wish it was fake he was like
but you got to understand you guys you
know how much more money I'd make if I
beat Jake Paul because then there's a
rematch I make more money and I fight
his brother and then maybe Connor fight
they're trying to argue maybe that they
paid him to take the fall absolutely I
felt that way I'm not gonna lie you
think you think no I'm gonna tell you
this okay I'm gonna tell you this the
reason why I felt that way I didn't feel
away until he knocked out Woodly
you thought the asking one the and then
the Nick when I when I was knocked out
Woodley then I went back and said oh
everybody's been taking a dive because
uh what is the real deal how much money
could how much money could it be worth
do you think we don't it ruins your
legacy like for like for Woodley or ask
especially for us some people some
people got a price though some people
some people but if I'm asking I'd be
like let's say it was let's say to your
point it was fake if I'm asking like no
I'll lose we ain't knocking me cold and
whatever 30 seconds
come on bro this is embarrassing you got
a point there but but you can't say that
it was us when he knocked out Willy like
the way he turned his glove though I
don't think so that just looks sucks to
me but I've also seen Jake train I'm the
the kids right yeah he worked his ass
off work is that and really for people
even with Anderson like oh that was fake
it's not and then they doctor they get
his tits they doctor the thing you know
so it looks like some fake punches and a
lot of people didn't buy the
pay-per-view so if that clip had like
four million views so if all you do is
see that like oh that's fake yeah yeah
yeah you're doing a disservice to it and
then also Nate Diaz's fan base like oh
it's fake okay well you're setting
yourself up for failure because he's
gonna fight Nate next that's probably
the fight that's gonna happen so if he
beats Nate your lord and savior Nate who
I'm a fan of right if Nate loses them
did Nate take a fall like are all his
fights fake until he fights tonight what
do you guys talking about how you think
he's gonna do against Nate though tough
fight for Nate before Anderson Silva
fight I was like man I told Jay I'm like
the Nate Diaz of the world the you know
the micro business this ain't for you
man and then when what he did against
Anderson like oh oh he he could beat
Nate the fight against Conor like man
well I thought I thought Anderson was
doing pretty good I thought Anderson was
piecing them up if I could remember the
fight I thought it was close I thought
early on and then and he was applying
pressure but Jake was actually using bot
like his footwork and stuff in this
counter I was like this dude can strip
for only having six fights that dude and
I was on that wave for a while and then
I was in Florida Florida on tour in
Miami and I was at the hotel and Uriah
Faber was there and before Jake was
gonna fight Ben Askin I'd been asking on
food truck and I was saying how Ben's
going to mop the floor with him blah
blah and then your eyes like shop I just
saw the show I'm telling you you're off
man he's like look and he had training
footage he showed me he's like I'm
telling look at this dude and I was like
that's Jake he's like yes bro yeah I
heard like his timing and his speed and
he's young and he's like he has all the
money in the world for the resources I'm
like
he's got all the money he's got he's
able to do it so Jake Paul is somebody
who had this career like people don't
remember but his YouTube videos were
like children's YouTube videos
it was literally like videos for like
eight-year-olds like it was the most
childish Disney Channel
and I think he had this moment where he
realized if I don't find something to
Pivot into then I'm basically going to
become a joke because he was like aging
up out of that content where like young
kids maybe weren't going to want to see
him doing all this kid [ __ ] I don't
think he likes making that content
anymore so he said [ __ ] it I'm gonna
like try try the boxing thing and then
like you know Logan like took it
relatively seriously for a while but
Jake took it to a whole different level
yeah they're not too different in the
past because Jake wants like to be a
legitimate boxer and like he'll accept
all challenges Logan's doing he just
wants the biggest biggest Payday the
most eyeballs possible but you know
Logan's not going for like the Anderson
silvas and the woodlands like Jake legit
wants you know he would go for an eight
I could I bet you after this he goes for
Cowboys hey I got no [ __ ] talking about
the guy but he wants to share a little
bit of that money let's go and it's this
Cowboy I'll bet my entire children's
college fund yeah
if I can get uh juice to the gills yeah
yeah right but Jake would do it but no
testing he's juicing yeah I say I'll do
it but no testing yeah I'm down to do it
I don't want he don't want to this he
does want to test because against Tommy
fury because he thinks Tommy's on stuff
he's like I'll do it but you have to
agree to Vada testing yeah I'm gonna
tell him I'm gonna call the doctor and
tell him let's boost this [ __ ] up yeah I
got a fight coming up let's turn the
knob to uh boil yeah what do you think
it does for the you know with your
legacy Cowboy You're such you know
you're a freaking Legend a loss to Jake
Paul at this stage of the game it's not
a big deal that doesn't discredit you I
don't like if Nate were to lose to him I
don't think who gives a [ __ ] like this
box but if it was a thing if it was a
thing where it was like there would
there would be a price on you to lose a
fight I mean you would you you have
enough you've done enough you have a
legacy what it would it like I mean not
even if if you did have let's say you
had a price that you would take the fall
for a fixed fight oh you're asking me to
take no no I'm just saying if there was
it and let's say that you'd know let's
say that you did have a price on taking
a fall for a fixed fight wouldn't that
also just kind of like an invalidate the
entirety of the sport yeah if that ever
got out
me coming from fighting in Japan I know
that some fights are works well for sure
I know that I've never done that I've
never done a Facebook but I've been
offered to do something I've been
offered to
um do work so I've been offered to take
Dives and I turned them down but I know
some Fighters that do it because um in
Japan it was different than UFC in the
UFC they're looking for the best and
right and in Japan they was looking for
the um most exciting fight and you could
lose a fight yeah
there's even those those things where
they might like all right so you you
could obviously knock this guy out in
one round but why don't you just keep it
interesting for three rounds and then
knock him out in the fourth you ever get
something like that I got offered I got
offered to like get get knocked out or
not tap out you know what I'm saying I
got office like that like they didn't
tell you when enough they just said and
do they boost the money yeah but but
they don't offered me that once and it
wasn't much more money and this isn't
Pride yeah it wasn't much more money
intimidating too yeah not the people
that was offering me oh yeah
but I know I'm not gonna say anything
else but I know some fights was where I
learned As We Know
some of the pro wrestlers that was
fighting yeah that's what they do right
yeah yeah I mean yeah some of the pro
wrestlers that was fighting in Japan
that was fake fights for sure damn you
got knocked out by Jake Paul right now
that in 20 years or 30 40 years like
when you die you feel like that's gonna
be like a big part of the conversation
about your fighting career or do you
think people would even bother to
mention that
uh for those of you watching the the
free fights the pigeon picture is over
if you want to continue watching this
Mayhem and the tatted up dude he's
getting his ass whooped by the hairy
back gentleman who's out of shape you
can go watch it right now you can buy
the paper on watchrnr.com it's some good
fights though yeah it's entertaining man
this dude in uh all tied up cannot fight
oh you you never knew how entertaining
it is watching people that don't know
how to fight fight oh dude every morning
I watch world star
every morning every single morning the
fight's on there bro the girl fights
they're grabbing hair and [ __ ] I like
watching Girl Fights on the street
because their titties come out yes yes
nobody
though man it's like a beer you know the
only thing worse than a warm beer is No
Beer you know there's no bad City yeah
yeah tell me when y'all didn't watch
natural geographic for the Africans oh
yeah yeah yeah when I was younger yeah
come on the only thing I thought we had
yeah we know we know yeah Cowboy secret
that likes black chicks
what was the secret yeah I said why
would that be he's never denied it
around hey you know who's crazy about
black chicks that [ __ ] me up every time
I think about it uh Saint Pierre oh I
know yeah he likes but he likes the ugly
ugliest yeah like he likes to be like
big ones yeah
bro I wanna yeah yeah Mike Dyson with
the wig ones I went up there yeah lizzo
once no I went up there one too by the
way yeah he finished him he was getting
dropped earlier but uh to your point I
didn't know that till I went to go spend
my camps with GSP hey there's big black
girls
but he explained to me so he grew up in
uh the the kids in school are really
mean to him like they'd bully him but
the black kids were his friends so the
and the black was always nice to him so
that's why he's attracted to because we
had nice support black people we nice
folks man yeah I don't know how it works
in Montreal but yeah I guess so but I'm
gonna tell you this this one I didn't
know he liked black chicks like that
since one time I was friends with this
um Playboy model she used to be on that
that that reality show with
um Kendra or whatever I'm bad with names
this is years ago oh yeah the old the
old day you have to have like three
girls oh Girls Next Door yeah
yeah she
came in a hot tub with just four black
girls yeah she was she was hot as [ __ ]
bro she was a 10 and she was like hey
hooked me up with um GSP and he was like
oh I was right there next to him I'm
like yeah yeah okay boom boom and he was
talking to her and stuff like that and
then he said give me give me a picture
all right bro I gave him a picture give
me a picture of him he's like oh no
she's not my type like what the [ __ ] who
she got to be everybody tonight I said
show me your time he showed me the title
I'm like damn yeah
she's not for you no she said can she
put on 200 pounds man she reminded me of
the mother from good time
this is America yeah we all hey we we
all the same we Americans
man Delia had the best joke about Hugh
Hefner he said Hugh Hefner was like his
buddy call was a Cayman they're doing
this me too movement they're they're
going after people and he left there was
like the me too move it
me too
I took the long sleeve dude and they
still came out that Dock and then a e
eight part series it's just him wild
wild
it's tough because what's dope out that
a e Doc is obviously there's like a few
girls who were telling like bats that
makes you look awful but then there was
like
10 of them ride or die we're like no
hold on it was a great time like
anybody's saying this stuff like maybe
they just had one bad experience those
are an exception in general Hugh took
care of everybody but you know it was
the talking about the 60s 70s 80s 90s
Wow have you ever been to one of his
parties at the Mansion never been I've
been to one they used to have fights
there I didn't know that Strike Force
how was it do anything with your wiener
no you know what um
I'm shy with like public sex and all
this stuff I don't know this guy yeah
yeah yeah
I met some cool people there were some
celebrities there and I met these two
hot Twins and I and I wanted them really
bad but my dumb ass took a girl with me
oh to the Playboy man yeah God and she
was [ __ ] blocking no because listen when
I got the invite she was there
so I wouldn't have said anything you got
a call she was no she was right when I
got the invite the person invited me in
person right next to my chicken did you
like the party I didn't think it was you
went to that one yeah was it the The
Grotto right that's where it goes down
yeah oh wow look at this guy getting his
ass beat right now we just covered just
shelling up this poor guy
he just had to be before he was married
right oh yeah when you're in the WC no
no no we it um we were just I had
clothes on like we didn't I didn't get
in the in the water we just I mean there
was people in the water but because they
used to have strike they used to have a
uh what was it and they have security to
you everywhere man I don't know I didn't
see people like have it in your mind you
think a Playboy party is just girls and
it wasn't anything like that like now
damn Missourian parties no that's a
different story different game I never
been to one of those you have to cut
I'll have to bring you next time you can
be my plus one all right all right let's
do it yeah Cowboy ain't bringing over
girl though damn blitzerian party hey I
wasn't simping just get that out your
head right now I wasn't
I was mad at him for inviting me like
right in front of her though I'm like no
I can't go hey but I was still holding
that chicks and I I got the I got the um
the twins phone number but right in
front of the chick I got the twins phone
number so the twins singular phone
number the two twins they just I got one
phone one [ __ ] this shirt but they they
both was down they were hot as Asian
girls they they really they they really
would do it together like that right I
don't know I didn't get that far but
it's too Asians like I think about it
there's like a male fantasy of like
hooking up with two twins oh yeah but
it's like is that kind of weird dude
yeah they're doing incest not you yeah
yeah it's their problems no listen but
they probably wouldn't you know that's
something they need to talk to
therapists
literally you tell me there's no
question for me right here
I have nothing on my confidence
they wouldn't do nothing to each other
but I know rappers who [ __ ] like a mom
and her daughter together and [ __ ] did
they do something so uh I'm not sure
that's disgusting yeah it is probably
not yeah good way to lose it but some of
these rappers definitely they got like
groupies that are like mother-daughter
teams wow yeah wow that's crazy I feel I
feel like uh with two more more than one
chick you get stressful no Adam I'd be
stressed out you're like an offensive
coordinator I'm gonna be real with you
like yeah a huge percentage of my like
off-camera threesomes where During the
period of like
the first like
2012 2016 2019
doing a lot of drugs and having a lot of
like Marathon sex sessions off Molly and
[ __ ]
wow so when you're in that mind State a
lot can go wrong my girl definitely
got mad and yelled at me through a vase
in my head a couple times but you know
why was he we got past it once you get
mad you you know the girl did Marathon
[ __ ] the other girl not giving his
wife no glove is that what it is if I
start eating other girl's ass too long
or if you just start [ __ ] the other
girl too long yeah you have to really
like know how to spread the love even
yeah I guess there's rules that's why
I'm getting stressed out that's what I'm
telling them you gotta be uh you got to
be kind of like really
but you do
if she doesn't really want to be doing
it but she's doing it to just be cool to
you
hey yeah I have a question yeah so I was
like watching you guys highlight reels
earlier what would your sexual highlight
reel be like if you had just had a
camera in the room for like all your
craziest sexual experience you know he
appoints all you ask a question like
that I just thought this up that's
creativity hey I almost hey just to say
though I almost had a foursome one so in
Japan you should have had more my first
threesome was in Japan yeah two Judo
chicks one chick had ear like [ __ ] yeah
damn hey hey real talk I was drunk as
hell I remember sucking on her ear
they said this don't feel like you're
here
at all bro
that's like chewing a piece of
cauliflower hey she was trying to hide
it she was all subconscious about
because she knew I was fighting she's
like oh your ears look good I'm like
yeah I got nothing and she was trying to
I said oh oh you're not so lucky yeah
I showed her that I don't give hey this
is my first threesome [ __ ] that yeah
wait what's your she was she a fighter
she was a Jew no she just did you know
it's huge in Japan there was two Judo
Fighters they was they was good they was
hot like in Japan like if a girl's a
little bit thicker they got a booty the
Japanese guys don't like them oh wow
yeah they like the skinny so skinny yeah
yeah yeah it's really being business
yeah I feel like we clean the house
there yeah yeah so I was saying about my
first almost foursome I was dating this
one stripper years ago dating for years
and Erica kawani broke me up with her I
did an interview while she's right next
to me he broke that relationship up she
was she was good she she was cool with
girls and all that stuff so we was going
to do a threesome I mean a foursome but
but she [ __ ] it up she didn't she she
like she thought hey she was like I know
he was all I got a big I got a big
octagon bed like it could fit like six
chicks damn and we was and you know it's
custom-made bed we really got octagon
bed [ __ ] yeah it kind of brings you back
no no yeah
baby
you can almost gone dead hey me and him
did a movie together in Thailand a
couple months ago this [ __ ] was
fat joking the whole goddamn time what
was the movie I was called three days in
Malay uh this dude you want to see
someone sweat through a [ __ ] burlap
slap this mother but it's Tyler house
with yeah bro I was sweating my ass I
heard you got to be careful the lady
boys in Thailand yeah no you don't gotta
be careful all you do is don't get drunk
and you can see them yeah maybe my
friend Brian Cowell's just gay but what
about that he films a show down there
the ones where you can't really like
tell them that's what Brian said because
they're they're structures like the bone
structures out there everyone is clean
and small but I could tell though but
but one time one time I was like nah my
trans radar is impeccable
no one's getting me I'm I'm confused
because I like a woman I don't know what
these dudes are getting confused
Brian said he didn't know you know what
I'm saying like that looks like a little
boy no Brian said he couldn't tell and
then he was uh filming uh The Hangover 2
out there and he was in a bar and this
lady was dancing he's like yeah she is
bad he's like therefore making out yeah
he's drunk and then you go in the back
room he's like dude he's like we're
making out oh yeah because I go down I
just get a handful of nuts yeah and I go
what'd you get what'd you do he goes I
don't want to hurt her feelings so I
kept making out with her and I was like
yeah you put politeness over heterosex
that's how good of a person
that's how good of a person Brian count
is though okay I'm gonna tell you this
is what that's what I learned from being
in Thailand twice all right if they look
super hot [ __ ] them like it's not even
worth it like no don't [ __ ] them don't
[ __ ] them okay don't [ __ ] them so I was
drunk I'd be very confused
okay if they super hot walk away yeah
walk away they super hot like they got
like fake tits fake lips I don't like
all that stuff I don't like all the fake
lips and this one girl had a fake ass
but it was a dude my cousin my cousin my
cousin invited like three girls up to
our table we said the VIP and two of the
girls were girls and one was a dude yeah
and we had been drinking and she had a
fake it had a big ass well you and your
boy like damn look at that yeah no we
couldn't see it before yeah damn you
know tiger with an ass like that then I
looked at my clothes like bro that's a
dude it was a dude yeah you go to
Thailand you need to look at any plastic
surgery as like a red flag like oh this
is quite likely to be yeah you've been
like a girl making herself look hotter
it's just a dude trying to dupe me yeah
you've been there right yeah yeah it's a
far fly it's a long sofa so far well I
don't what what's the end goal with the
[ __ ] thing I don't get it like like
Brian the dude they they cut the dick
off and they still got it ah in his case
yeah so what you they make y'all do you
end up bringing them home and they're
hoping you just don't care and there's
something about stuff yeah there's a ton
of people who go there who want that
yeah yeah and they're like oh I didn't
know you're like every time though
oh yeah yeah it's tough yeah [ __ ]
everybody up but I got some friends out
that live out there and they said a lot
of people do go out there for the later
boys though so of course yeah and act
like oh God I have no idea so think
about it they they there to make money
right yeah
totally oh he just got dropped too they
call them
hakamania instead of Hulkamania you
never want to wear shirts like the fact
in the pool it's like yeah you're just
looking more attention you're bringing
more attention to yourself dude if my
fat ass [ __ ] today I'll be wearing a
shirt
so you think people go over there to
[ __ ] dudes yeah Thailand oh there's a
few oh yeah oh he just dropped homeboy
there's a there's a few businessmen are
like man I got duped again like bro that
is your third time this year he's like
yeah it's crazy they they want to play
it out listen like they're gay men but
they they want to use that as a cup I
know they're like man I started making
other dudes and I was like [ __ ] we
already go back to the hotel room so I
just let a booty race
that's what my boy Brian said he's my
only evidence
I knew it right away but he was in the
elevator he looked ashamed a little bit
he had his head down you guys would need
me talking to Biden right now like man
we gotta figure out how we got to get
cowboy back because he's in prison in
Thailand right now yeah murder oh no but
they but they know this but they know
they're not gonna mess with you they
they know the vibe oh my God if you want
to get tricked you can hear that in the
voice there's so many things like I've
never been tricked in person like in the
picture somebody showed me yeah I I've
been tricked over pictures but in person
I you know what I started doing I got
I'm so sick of it because I hate when
they lie I don't keep getting catfished
or what no no no he's like I'm sick of
these big dicks in my face yeah I'm sick
of it because people it was so many
there and they'd be trying to trick
people yeah so whenever a lady in the
case come and touch you yeah down the
street right yeah and whenever I'm
walking down the street and the hooker
touching me I look at I'm like uh
ladybug
and they get they get mad but but they
probably know after a while like he's
not he knows yeah he has a good iPhone
yeah
the professionals if they're tricking
[ __ ] like what what's because
they're because they're batting up
they're batting about 90 that's that's
my thing if you're tricking someone
normally what is yeah what is really
because they have a success they have a
high success rate they're bad about
myself as a very intentional human being
and I will come straight off the gate
off the table like okay look I'm a fat
insecure dude with a little dick you
into that baby let's do this thing yeah
you know what I mean no surprises with
Teddy
that's just where I get I mean live how
you want to live do whatever you want
dress how you want yeah whatever yeah
view yourself as whatever or I mean I'll
even call you whatever you want to be
called I love you know I do I would not
I would not you know like I miss
I would try to be woken up to not Miss
Jen to anyone but at least just be
honest with me about what you're going
through politics
would you date a trans I know I would
not no and I would like that but you
accept them but no yeah of course yes
dude I'd be so into like as long as they
intentionally but like why would we why
would it be like a thing that you was
hiding or yeah
but again the reason the reason they do
that is because
me personally I'm not going to Thailand
too far
if anything if anything I'm gonna set
the bar so low that if you do get into
belly then you're gonna have nothing but
absolutely a blast because it's gonna be
just such a long time yeah he actually
killed that [ __ ] yeah yeah
you think you got a girl you go back to
the hotel you find out it's a dude and
you're like yo they didn't show her face
one time [ __ ] yeah I know it's they
they're playing a dicey game
probably they're also hookers right so
they don't you know they're rolling the
dice
right they're rolling the dice I would
assume I would assume that 100 of the
later boys there they got to pay off all
those surgeries and [ __ ] yeah yeah
but a dick
yeah I don't I don't I wish Brian was
there and they get back to the hotel
room and they're like oh gotcha and then
probably a lot of them have fake vaginas
too to be honest or they're just getting
[ __ ] in the ass or giving head yeah I
don't know I never took one back to the
hotel yeah
maybe maybe the lights are off and
you're just like man that some Firehead
I don't I don't know how it works but
guys the drunk guys are drunk enough
they probably fall for it you know I was
gonna do it you know I like to prank my
friends I was going to get one of my
friends really drunk and send a [ __ ]
just see how it goes just see how I go
just to get pictures and videos
or whatever yeah yeah yeah I was
wondering this guy's name's the [ __ ]
sickest streets I didn't have a heart
because I thought about it like I'd be
mad somebody did it to me oh yeah yeah
should get some Thai lady boys over here
after the fights
no no okay
no she doesn't see how they're doing
yeah just talk to them that hucca Mania
got drunk he was talking about the
gender thing you don't think there's
just two genders
man I would say I will say I would say I
would not I would not um
man I I would say that I would allow I
think people can be whatever they want
to be
um they're allowed to have whatever they
want to have and they are totally
allowed to coexist with me and do
whatever they need to do but I just I I
would think though like I don't mean to
put you on the spotlight no no I totally
don't mind being on the spot I I just
respect you just being honest about what
it is that you applied
you know what I'm saying like yeah I
mean do I think that I think I think uh
I think when you're born or like the way
that you're like it I mean I think I
think there's science you know and I
think there's uh humanity and I think uh
we're in a place in time where there's
blurred lines between science and
humanity and that's nothing that I can
do because I don't know [ __ ] about
either of them right so I won't
speculate on it but I just if you're
gonna if you're gonna be
intentional about your decision to be
one both this that or however you view
yourself or I if you want to be uh I
don't know all the genders that they are
putting out but if you say if you say yo
I'm cisgendered or I'm
I I'm they are them like dude okay sure
I don't have kids but yeah but as as a
day of them if you if you just come
honest with me and say hey call me they
come on I mean at least I could do is
just it doesn't affect me at all
in real life yeah like when somebody
uses they in them because I know one and
it is very difficult to [ __ ] insert
that [ __ ] it's also it's just not you
know it's like muscle memory I'm trying
to be polite but it's hard to be like oh
it is they went to the store when you
want to say he or she it is it's very
very hard do they get upset when you
forget uh I've never been around
somebody who is like self-righteous
enough that they would get and most are
cool I don't care like if you want me to
call you [ __ ] Sally yeah sure exactly
and you want to say you're a girl yeah
sure but you shouldn't be allowed to go
into the girl's bathroom that's where it
gets diced
you are a boy or you are a girl there's
no there I like that especially once you
have kids once you have kids oh man my
kids know how located four and two but
my four-year-old no he's like oh we
gotta separate the Bulls from the four
and two and the other boys boys two yeah
I have two boys two yeah six and six and
three and what you're I got four kids I
got three boys and one girl but it's
just like this if you if you are a boy
and you want me to call you a girl I I
got no problem with that like that's
like yeah exactly dude
I got I got enough love for like
Humanity to know that if I was and I'm
not facing that but if I was facing that
then I'd hope that you guys would [ __ ]
yeah people back to the house facing
that and you totally would yeah yeah but
I'd also I'd also come straight and say
hey this is who I am this is what you
know I would not be here trying to like
and make you think that I was this when
I was like I would not be here deceiving
someone that's right that's where it
gets weird for me it's like well I
respect your Humanity over anything when
you when you start deceiving me that's
when you don't respect my humanity and
that's when it's like okay but like
don't like don't do it that's where it
gets [ __ ] it's weird just be honest
with it
see two-year-old I'm gonna find out soon
but you you shot this movie then you I
mean you straight Hollywood now you're
yeah you're the next door not Marvel's
coming oh man let's hope so you did a
movie with uh Gina Carano too yeah with
your mood Gina Rampage and I did a movie
together uh we've done two movies yeah
um are you getting out into acting world
yeah I'm loving it man can I tell y'all
something about his acting I did the
first movie with him in in Vegas and I I
hope I can say this I hope I'm not
giving away I had I had to kill his
girlfriend in the movie right spoiler
alert spoiler there's a movie out yeah
I'm not gonna say that yeah
it's coming uh month I think yeah yeah
and
I was so impressed by his acting when I
killed his [ __ ] I mean his girlfriend
she was hot too and I had I had to blast
this [ __ ] no I heard uh Gina Carano was
saying I think she was talking to Rogan
confused and when I did the movie with
him in um in Thailand he had seen what
he had to cry Cowboys crying I never
cried I've done like [ __ ] nine ten
movies
I wonder if I figure how tiny I am I was
like just before I was out there
training for a fight so I was right he
went in 60 162. you're trying to
maintain weight not eating stuff yeah
damn fought a couple weeks he was a
soldier he was a soldier for them
because because he had to fight right
away he he promised to do the movie
gangs contracts and he did the movie and
then still had to go no I know your
fight got pushed it back there right
right I got hurt or something I knew so
in the movies in the movie you guys are
inviting what is this like what is it so
you guys I mean you're killing folks you
gotta look at your gangster or like what
is it what are the two different movies
we done together the first one I was a
game do you want to see the movie yeah I
have the clip I would love to see it I
just well he's a great especially now I
can I can go I can go watch it and be
like I knew Cowboys legit when Gina
Carano was a cowboy
enthusiastic
you know that's my boy right there right
you know that's my boy right coaching
nothing like that like I just
[ __ ] know how to act like this
some people can just do it you know what
I'm saying that's like Michael Rapport
same thing no acting coach
just started yeah he just got into it
when he's young some people just have to
give Cowboys
oh we can't have the volume yeah it'll
kick us off it'll kick us off yeah you
might have to show him after him you can
show him afterwards yeah
oh it's like a a military like yeah
1940s this is already out this trailer
no the trailer uh the trailer is yeah
and they mean while these boys are just
throwing hay makers this guy came in in
pants
ah ballsy move barstools letting
everything go that's part of the fun uh
it's audio it's tough yeah yeah Rampage
has a cool fight scene coming here too
the Opera yeah I haven't seen much of it
you know what I like Cowboys when you do
uh all this acting you're not just you
know like The Bodyguard or the tough guy
can fight like you're acting you know
what I'm saying yeah
he plays a soldier
and and a soldier not on just but just
wouldn't tell y'all he was a gay Soldier
and his boyfriend died
I feel like cowboy would pass pass on
that role yeah I'm joking he didn't do
that
and that dude right there that was just
fighting that that was Peter Pan as a
kid oh damn hook oh sick yeah I know a
white guy who got offered a movie Road
where he had to call somebody the n-word
and he didn't take it and I think about
that [ __ ] all the time is it Django nah
but it was like a [ __ ] it was a scene
where you know he was like aggressively
he would have been aggressively calling
a black person the N word I just thought
it was too risky for his career if it
was a like Kenny clutch a movie like
Quentin Tarantino like Marvel Marvel's
never gonna do that but like if you're
the one guy in Black Panther three drop
in the pools I kind of feel like it
would be worth it
those lines this dude right here right
there Boop boom oh that was good
you know why is like Clark County in the
corner of this fight just hyping
everybody up to you all right
he's rocking the Superman shirt yeah
Superman is there a release there but
you know when it comes the super
instrumental it comes out pretty soon
but you can see how to handle hair there
now my hair games on point dude whatever
you're doing whatever you're doing tell
Callan yeah I did I just got on FaceTime
hook him up with your person because
he's here you got the hairline surgery I
went to Turkey and got trans turkey
the best bro I don't know why you got to
go to Turkey though I did it right here
I mean it was probably more expensive
than it would be in Turkey but I didn't
have to fly to Turkey you know yeah
but I have a bunch of friends who got
into turkey too so apparently they're
doing something yeah turkey is good for
a hair transplant and then it's like
Columbia for acids for women right in
titties Miami yeah dude I I saw this uh
I saw this video the other day where it
was like uh you know a little Tick Tock
place where it was like all these people
on my plane have just had bbls and they
can't sit so it's easy I saw I was like
15 girls it's like 15 ladies all these
flights back from Miami
they're sitting like this in their
chairs
Miami to California like right here like
four or five hours having a look at
everybody behind you in the eyes because
your ass can't sit down no shame
on it after you get it done they take
the fat out of it
you're really not supposed to sit down
for a while I think
I guess they just got to be like you
gotta sleep on your stomach at Spirit
Airlines Columbia I couldn't do it
you're lucky you get a seat belt you
want yeah
right how long you can't sit for though
like six weeks you know you're not
supposed to sit on it it's also the most
risky surgery there is six weeks yeah
but I think it's not that risky when you
look at like the real deal people to do
it and the reason why it's risky is
because they do so many [ __ ]
versions and shopping malls and [ __ ]
like that where they're putting all
kinds of weird stuff in your ass yeah
I'm telling you I'm gonna ask
connoisseur I'm gonna tell you this mom
died yeah
you could tell but it's like hard to
tell but I've had chicks who had like
fake asses from like 10 15 years ago and
it just feels like a big old piece in
there and it is it might look out right
in the clothes sometimes but it feels
terrible so I feel like a fake titty
kind of where is it blockier and harder
I'm gonna tell you this this is what I
don't like see look me I'm I'm like a a
four four and a half so I'm just no
you're staying on the um
so when women they get out of this fake
[ __ ] they get the fake lips and they get
fake ass their confidence go through the
roof so you you remember when it was
just fake boobs an ugly girl could get
fat then they said they're hot they say
to themselves they're hot so imagine the
confidence that they're getting when
they get fake lips and a fake ass and
they still be the same chick with
[ __ ] wigs and weave they get fake
lips and fake ass treating everybody
different
and I hate that [ __ ] it's not only the
way they look this is the way they act
attitude the attitude well some but some
some of those ugly ducklings get all
that work done they have that sweet
personality and now they get the ass
titties and but this is why you got some
different in cells and [ __ ] is because
you got regular dudes in high school and
all the hot chicks from their high
school they turn 18 and they're like
flying to Dan bilzerian's house and
they're on yachts in Miami and [ __ ]
that's right all these dudes are just
angry as [ __ ] because they can't even
get [ __ ] all the fire [ __ ] just left
right see all these girls they graduate
and then they come to LA and Miami and
they're with the celebrities
our kids your boys you can think about
your boy he got a daughter so it's
different I got one daughter so I know
but we gotta think about is our boys I
got two I got two boys that are 22 and
23. and and my oldest son he said he
just said [ __ ] he said I just like myths
he like older chicks he said young
chicks he said they different he said
they different like a mature woman yeah
he likes the older ones and he like the
young chicks that he said their mind
like they all into like crazy [ __ ]
Tick Tock drugs and vaping yeah Euphoria
so you just gotta think about your kids
like the dating pool for for the Next
Generation it's gonna be weird all these
girls got all these plastic surgery
Botox young girls getting Botox now wait
so you said you said you got two of them
yeah two boys I got three boys three
boys and you got two red two boys yeah
seven they're six and three and you're
my I got I got a 23 year old 22 and a
17. hey you got a dog she's about to be
one or something
I think Cowboys how about you boys I
have two boys and a baby do any second
oh damn yeah
until she's 16 yeah
dude it's so scary because I'm starting
to I'm I I say like this I'm I'm finally
my first like uh alcohol adult
relationship with the woman that I'm
like really love with your first ever I
I say it as like it's a it's an adult
relationship you're taking it serious
and and we're not like it's not like
we're like doing what I've done in all
my other relationships where we're just
kind of honestly just punishing to each
other for like the way we've been hurt
by other people yeah you know what I'm
saying this is my first relationship as
well
yeah we're not like punishing somebody
for somebody that treated me that you
know like you like well you really like
love somebody and you work at their
shoes yeah so I so we're adult we're
like having like settled down like real
life and having a place in my career
where uh do I beat her ass do you eat
her ass oh God [ __ ] right up
here
my boy he's from Georgia bro well I hate
that booty I hate that booty God damn it
Georgia bro yes sir I hate that booty
well you're in love though but so but I
thought you know I think about too man
like with children having children now
it's just such a scary thought because
you know they're just so exposed to like
even even when I think about my mom too
like you know my dad was always really
good to me but but my mom her her dad
was a Pentecostal Pastor I don't blame
it but for a lot of things she tried to
like kind of keep me like sheltered and
keep me and protect me from it you know
and then it was stuff that I'd end up
finding out later but for these kids
coming up now like they're eating
Sheltering you can do social media
social media [ __ ] them because they're
coming already exposed to everything
right the moment
when Rampage talks about like all the
plastic surgery and stuff you gotta
realize like that that Kylie Jenner that
you know that's their North Star so when
they realize like a lot of that and they
buy her makeup it's like you can put all
that makeup on yeah that's what they
want like the Jenner family it's like a
lineage of the parents teaching the
daughters to like spend their entire
life fixated on how to be as hot as
possible Right which for me as a parent
is like you need to fight against that
like TV and the media and [ __ ] are going
to be convincing your daughter that her
only worth is her looks like right you
have to like to emphasize education and
all this [ __ ] but when you look at the
Kardashians it's like the opposite like
it's just like no you will be judged
only by how you look so let's just
prepare for that yep
there is right and then and they're
exposed to everything all of it right
now
for my kids I learned from my kids none
of them are really big on social media
because I try to follow them especially
my daughter to see what she'd be posting
and a lot of them not really they're not
really big on social media none of them
none of none of my kids none not four
yeah but but your kids are like 20
something it's a little different the
oldest one even the youngest one my
daughter she's been she's going to be 16
at the end of the month there's some
smart kids out like there's a there's a
trend too where kids are like super
anti-twitter and stuff where you know
they don't they don't like certain
things I follow them all on Instagram
they don't post [ __ ]
unless they got me yeah they got me
shadowed or something I don't know but
it's Gotta Be It's gotta be real
situation where these kids gotta like
you know as as a parent now I can
imagine and I I can't speculate because
I don't have but as a parent now I can
imagine it's like you know you can't you
can't just take the ball for him at this
point you just got to kind of like let
him have the ball and just be like you
know I'm here to pitch it back like you
can pitch it we gotta give them the
tools
you got to just all you can do now is
just like help them navigate the
[ __ ] they're going through well you
can't keep them but once again look at
them in all his glory become the smidge
the door man no Connor
smidge
and he's fighting another [ __ ] named
raging yeah what do we call it small
people but I've seen I've seen Smith go
at it before this dude it's a whole new
world man I still say a lot of
old-fashioned words but me too me too
you're safe with the business you're in
but yeah yeah on TV like uh dude I do
find like one of my one of my one of my
closest closest friends in the world and
all who is a little person I mean he'll
he'll tell you like the the world term
about it but he's also like well he
Embraces the [ __ ] out of what he is he
wouldn't care that you said that like
most don't I don't want to be just
social media I don't want to be around
anyone where I can't say that your shirt
is gay with and they get offended that's
what I'm doing like I got to be able to
say that yeah but anyways yeah but you
know it's that thing it's usually not
even the people that like are that would
be offended by it but Social Services
everybody else yeah he's right he's
right the smartest of course unless and
of course we're saying anywhere which is
that that's a horrible difference I
can't
the Cowboys
the four people at the stable can't say
well I'm gonna tell y'all something
about me what y'all might not know like
me I I tried my I don't think I've ever
stayed away from I can't stand Prejudice
in anything so I don't want to be
prejudiced against anything like that's
why I don't care about people's
religions their race like what you
talking about earlier was you respect I
don't I don't care about trans gay
people they don't bother me at all I
don't I don't want to be president
because I grew up in Memphis in the
South was Prejudice and nothing I feel
like if you're not racist you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want because I
know I'm not I know I'm not racist I'm
gonna tell you when I found out 100 that
I wasn't racist when my daughter brought
home her first boyfriend he was white
thank you and I didn't give a [ __ ] all I
cared about deep down was was you get to
it I'm a Somalian I won't give a [ __ ]
but Samoan I won't give a [ __ ] okay
yeah but
but
yeah
even if I knew the answer
I knew it was going like America it's
just America bro we just we just so
sensitive I feel like if you're not
racist you can say whatever the [ __ ] you
want and that's like I always felt like
I wasn't racist but when my when my
daughter brought home a a white
boyfriend that was a real twice which is
Japanese she had a problem with it
Asian friends that I have like the
Asians like Koreans don't like Japanese
Japanese hate Chinese like the the with
them it gets they died but I'll even say
dude even if out of out of uh like let's
say we best friends and you give me a
pass to say this particular word and
then I feel comfortable enough to say
this particular word
um what yeah I wouldn't say that out of
not only respect for you but also you
remember when you were like fourth or
fifth grade and you're sitting back at a
bus and you and all your friends is like
you know way too young y'all don't even
know how to use curse words you're like
God damn [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hell
yeah baby you just using curse words to
use curse words and then you happen to
accidentally slip up and say something
in front of your parents and then now
you're in trouble yeah so what happens
with even if you you had given me the
best to say that word
my vocabulary and then it slips up in
the wrong so just get it the [ __ ] out of
here my son said the f word in front of
everybody else yeah you know just get it
out of your vocabulary and you won't you
won't have an issue with
and out of respect or yeah our society
the way it is out of respect for you but
but most people are like this the
problem is social media will give you uh
it's out of context it's so extreme on
social media that's not how the real
world is like it's not that polarizing
that when you go I'm on the road all the
time you know I knew Trump was going
before all this stuff because I'd be in
Boise I'd be in Texas uh Baltimore I'd
be all over and people like Trump's not
winning I'm like bro I'm on the streets
I'm telling you this dude about to win
everybody going for this dude when it
back then not now so much but back down
I'm telling you'd be surprised how many
people going for Trump now
they're going for DeSantis Kanye now
now
you're supposed to have Kanye on your
show yeah hey Bill last minute they said
he lost his voice or something that's a
that's a bad excuse yeah
I wouldn't cancel the show if I was a
big one but I could definitely still
come in here and run my mouth I would
have liked to see you in concert
I can still talk
you know I mean yeah I'm not backing
down because I've talked tons of [ __ ]
about him over the years and the weird
part about it is because his little Nazi
homie Nick Fuentes we interviewed him a
few months ago right how did that which
is like in his Nazi homie he has a he's
a white body Melissa I guess you could
call it he claims he doesn't like hate
black people but he basically feels like
the races should like live in their own
little sections
he's like probably the most famous like
racist guy in America and he influences
Kanye then also he doesn't believe the
Holocaust is real I think that's all
fake so but we did it with him and we we
were honest you know we gave him a
straight up interview we didn't try to
you know gotcha haha you're a piece of
[ __ ] whatever we gave him a straight up
interview and so I think because of that
he wanted to bring Kanye around even
though I've been
critical of Kanye as far as his music or
just what he's doing lately more about
like the insane way that he was treating
his ex-wife while they were sorting out
the [ __ ] with the kids and then more
recently with you're talking about with
Kim yeah like there was all that crazy
[ __ ] about him like trying to track her
down at like parties and stuff and he
was just going on these crazy rants
about he was naming and shaming the
[ __ ] school that the kids go to and
then they had a higher extra security at
the school to protect the kids because
he's naming like think about that no
matter how much you hated your [ __ ]
ex-wife imagine naming the school that
your kids go to on social media when
you're that famous you know that there's
a lot of crazy people I'm not vouching
for but Adam so a he was not because
he's starting his own school right up
the street called donda and imagine
doing it because it will support your
business yeah insane but even worse no
that's worse but Juan that's [ __ ]
worse no Teddy I'm not defending but
when he was going crazy it was his uh
his kid's birthday party and they
wouldn't allow him into the birthday
party right which I understand so and
then the soccer game with TMZ's like oh
Connie is going crazy right Kim's
Kardashian security won't allow him to
hug his son who isn't seen in weeks they
stopped himself so imagine so there's
two sides of the story don't get me
wrong I don't co-sign anything
you've become convinced that the dad is
a [ __ ] maniac and you just like don't
you want to like take the time that he's
gonna spend with the kid and sort of be
in charge of how that plays out because
you could just imagine like I'm sure her
experience at this birthday party would
have been ruined if he was there right
at this point in their relationship and
I believe that there was like another
birthday party that he had for the kid
that was like a separate thing so that's
why she felt like oh there's like
multiple birthday parties and that's why
she felt like yeah
birthday party is he a maniac with his
kids though he's not I've seen him
personally you know you gotta think
about that like a lot of time a lot of
time moms will use your kids as Weapons
like me same thing like me dude I
thought I was a perfect husband and I
tried to be like the best dad ever and
still my ex-wife I've taken care of her
all these years and she still try to and
like um
talk [ __ ] about me to my kids and stuff
all right well that's just seeing that
that's where I go but that's where I get
this when I see people when I see people
like when I see people that like keep
you know their kids from the other
parent whatever the circumstance is it's
like uh just so weird for me because
that's just ultimately punishing the
kids exactly
brothers and they got a different mom
you know and they that that Mom has been
he's schizophrenic bipolar crazy in and
out of prison their whole lives and I
did a lot a lot of time where I had to
like kind of really step up and raise
them boys a lot but you know one thing
my dad always did and you know a lot of
a lot of folks aren't lucky enough to
have like a father like I mean I could
tell you all day every day like my
father Jesus on his best they couldn't
touch like my my father's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but he always
dude still he's like dude he's in is now
that they're all older like my little
brother is 21 the other's 20 or 22 and
20. can they sing no they can't no but
they're they're 22 and 20 and now know
that like you know their mom is still
part of their life and they have at
least been able to even if it was
supervised visits or it was like times
that like he would never like try to
like take them from their mother and
talk [ __ ] about it because he would just
yeah you just you just hurt the kid that
way he's like he's like I'm gonna just
let them like let them get into it and
maybe I'll like I'll be there to like
not let them get hurt by their mama but
I'll definitely let them they need a Mom
decide hey Adam y'all let them decide
for themselves who their mama is I'm not
gonna tell him I'm not gonna tell them
their mom is a horrible person I'm gonna
let them decide eventually when they get
older that like trust me I need to
decide that for myself
people didn't know that I was a singer
single dad I was in the dead when I was
fighting in Pride man I had a
three-year-old son when I first started
fighting there gangster I was the same I
was a single parent I can't imagine
fighting in heaven yeah no I had to go
overseas babysit my my son yeah but you
have good babysitters
well you know one one of my friends he
was my teammate he he he had like a kid
that was a little bit older than my kid
so he he he knew about kids you know
what I'm saying so I was like okay he's
convenient yeah it was convenient but
you know it was hard and I started
dating this one Hawaiian girl and um she
was she was babysitting my kid uh while
I was fighting in Japan then I met my
ex-wife over there so what I did was I'm
like man I need a I need a baby mama I
need a mama for this kid because it's
hard for it's different for it's
different for kids when they grow
without their mom damn look what it is
look at you look at your Rampage hey I'm
gonna get like that one I'm gonna get
back like that one day dude
I don't want to pay nine thousand
dollars a month
hey then Rampage you don't want it bad
enough because liver King was paying 11.
he's paying nine I don't wanna I got I
got so I got so much [ __ ] I'm I'm I'm
trying to be like cowboy he got 50 acres
I got [ __ ] 78 I'm trying to 500.00
he's doing steroids on these Acres yeah
in New Mexico yeah
500 Acres you ever have a girl who wants
you to [ __ ] her with the chain on
like throwback I've had girls I have
girls that ask crazy stuff she's like
can you stop by Home Depot on the way
here
the power they wanted me to do the
Powerball
yeah I have girls but look like I was
saying well I'm gonna say to you oh we
have the small fight coming up though
wow we'll pay attention
the mothers only do that [ __ ] to to men
who really wants to be in their kids
life yeah because they know it's the
easiest way exactly man and there's too
many kids growing up without a doubting
but when they grow without a mom it's
different so different
they were wet the bed so I had so I had
two I was singing my ex-wife left me
because I had to get because of my son
is 22 now that's why she that's why I
ended my divorce and same thing Second
Street I didn't watch my dad go try to
get custody of his kids if we take it
from your mom and then it was just such
a man-hating like situation too because
it's usually the other way around hey
you think it works so hard
human being like it was so hard because
it's usually the other way around
the kid different yeah cause it's got to
be tough that's way that's way less
natural the kid need both parents but
when they grow up without the mom I got
something man I didn't know I didn't
know what to do I didn't know I didn't
know what to do I think my kids they
turned out all right but they didn't go
to college or nothing like that you know
I was busy working trying to shoot them
oh [ __ ]
Rush him which one is smidge the one
with the uh
man I love that man I live for that it
said world's uh strongest
that's them just being silly but like
picture him benching and like imagine
the range of motion three inches like
three inches the bench 300 pounds you
gotta have a hell of a spotter bro yo
did they go at it I've seen the smidge
character fight before he's aggressive
when you get two small people in the
room it's like a Siamese fighting fish
he's three and three uh four two
this is science too every small person
cheeked up
oh yeah yeah they're thick as [ __ ]
cheeked up right it's science we got
natural BBL yeah because the because the
just the the the distribution a small
person absolutely not sir I would okay
y'all open the door y'all open up the
door for this and I gotta I really just
gotta kind of get it off my chest please
do at least that's a small person no I
did not but uh so you know how like you
know how your algorithm works and it'll
have to be something to even watch like
you don't have to do something you even
like but once it sees you stop suggest
and looking yeah it knows it suggests
that to you again and so I was in Europe
this year and my girl was with me on
tour and she went to my explore page and
she kept seeing a bunch of like little
people that were like fine and thick and
as and she tried to come at me she was
not skinny maybe she was like baby you
gotta you got a little person fetishing
like and I was like no I'm like it's
just a virus I didn't like them I was
just I was like honestly that's even
[ __ ] up for you to say because you
just think they're different than
anybody else I just think I think I
think a bad [ __ ] is a bad word
so I'm trying to turn it on her which is
also like yes and so then like next
thing you know I'm like a few days later
I'm still scrolling and I keep seeing
this [ __ ] happen and I was like
[ __ ] maybe she was right maybe I did
have like some sort of like weird little
person thing that I like or like maybe
there's some curiosity oh don't let her
[ __ ] with your hair well no I would just
say I would just say if having a little
person fetish is wrong and I won't be
right
and I love her more than anything she'll
hear this and be like [ __ ] I knew it
no so but I just had to get that off my
door
I told this one girl she had sexy feet
and now she think I got a foot fetish
and honestly I don't I don't have
anything she just had some outstanding
feet well no she just had sexy feet I
like I like if a girl has sexy feet I'm
gonna give him a compliment oh you got
sexy I'll only notice their feet if
they're like atrocious if they have like
Raptor claws other than that I don't
know I'm not a food guy no I I like feet
but I don't have a foot fetish I'ma ask
connoisseur but I don't have an ass
fetish yeah what the [ __ ] you laughing
at yeah you can't you can't you can't
appreciate it without having it if you
love ass what is making you say that you
don't have an ass fetish just because
you don't smell the [ __ ] or you don't
want to eat [ __ ] out of it you don't
have a
because before bbl's I I like I like the
little ring girl yeah and a bunny outfit
you got a bag of Kratom right there or
what what she had three cheese is it is
it it's got an edible parade
I mean it's some sort of like it looks
kind of like weed but I'm guessing it's
not weeds so it's gonna be some uh micro
dose gummies
like before bbl's I could always tell
like if a girl had a real ass or not
right and I just appreciate real body
real body parts oh yeah and I really I
like the shape of of certain girls asses
like if a girl's ass is too big too
cottage cheese I'm not into it like even
because some girls they don't have that
big of an ass right and they think that
they think that their ass is not good
every day yeah every day I look at it
I'm like wow I'm so glad you have that
surgery
I've seen her only well I can tell you
I'll tell you between me and you man it
might we might can be totally wrong but
if you ever need an enabler I totally
think exactly like you do I think it
maybe I do have foot fetish maybe I
don't know but I don't I just I I it's
just so wrong that I appreciate a good
book
I don't know
I like titties just as much I like feet
I don't go out of my way to look up ever
since my girl was pregnant now whenever
I see a hot chick who's pregnant I like
feel like extremely drawn towards I just
want to look at it
yeah some of the best books I've ever
had yeah
it feels so good really good feels good
bro you put them on the side they can
barely move but it feels so good oh it
feels good that's right
no you scared the baby there's all kinds
of [ __ ]
are you that long do you think you
stabbing your baby's head yeah it's not
for me yeah it's not my thing oh really
I had to worry about that
Adam goes you talking to the right guy
my girl told me you're supposed to [ __ ]
her because it'll make the baby come out
sooner yeah I've heard that doctor said
that too true it's true it's a good
excuse I told the doctor you're
disgusting disgusting no no it's true
when I was married my ex-wife we went to
a wedding and she came home and she was
horny as [ __ ] and I'm like no it was too
soon it was too too late in the
pregnancy I was like no I don't want to
I don't want to do this I was worried
about the same thing yeah no and she
[ __ ] pretty much raped me and
my boy the victory
when I was married my wife she knew
exactly how to get me up she knew
exactly what to do she did it she jumped
on it
next thing you know she was in labor the
next day and the baby her first baby she
didn't take the epiderm do you want you
want more cookies
yeah he just had like the best
pronunciation yeah
you ever say it like that put on that
new music and we say stroke strawberries
come on strawberry it's great yeah yeah
when's the last time you went down there
down there
I was in Memphis a couple of months ago
I told you I brought some some land that
I was trying to be like Cowboys they're
trying to get to Memphis it's 500. yeah
so as soon as I found he had 500 Acres I
was like do you believe that Memphis has
Darkness
this is a debate that I've heard online
what is it does Memphis have dark energy
oh it's haunted for sure I don't know
about hunting like violent energy or
just like yeah
it's like it's like New Orleans in
Memphis no no when I was in Nashville
they were like yo like Memphis like yeah
you can go to Memphis but it's different
there's a different vibe Nashville's
very light-hearted Memphis has dark I
don't know this race is talk okay
too sweet and kind of protected in a
weird [ __ ] way where it's kind of
like goddamn life
okay well like but but certain areas I'm
not gonna lie but I'm gonna tell you
something I've been living out here in
California for over 20 years right but
yeah certain areas in Memphis I don't
[ __ ] with nor should you yeah there's
certain areas everywhere you shouldn't
yeah
your hometown you think you can [ __ ]
with it even me even me being like one
of the only it's on like two
like people better or like Spirits bad
area no both from Memphis Yeah gang
bangers there's just a lot of like
famous rappers who got killed out there
too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I feel
like LA's the last spot for that but
they were putting them stuff they're
putting themselves they're putting
themselves out there like that yeah
I don't do no [ __ ] like that I don't
have enemies anywhere I feel like I can
go anywhere and I'll be cool with
anybody yeah
I mean I'm gonna put it like this three
six mile for you the first like
important rappers to really come out of
Memphis who are rapping about snorting
cocaine and [ __ ] having like Devil
worshiping orgies and [ __ ] like 25
[ __ ] years ago yeah I'm just saying
Memphis came up with that way before
everybody else in rap was putting that
[ __ ] out there I'm friends with DJ Paul
I like him no he's not an actual devil
worshiper a great guy actually he was
like putting out that kind of lyrical
yeah yeah he writing I asked him I said
straight up DJ Paul are you you a devil
worship he said no man I'm not with this
that's their hustle right you know it's
just imagery I'm gonna tell to God you
know saying I'm a Child of God it's like
metal dance yeah exactly that's just
rock and roll yeah I think Marilyn
Manson's a Satanist you know I don't
think so no dude he might be a vampire
but he's a weirdo honestly I think he is
but that's just rock and roll right
there bro like three six just on some
rock and roll Metallica
Aussie too uh same thing right he would
do that weird thing shouldn't put the
hat off a bat
how much you weigh
but you got titties I don't got titties
yet I don't got titties yet
no no no just scoot over I give titties
I give titties props when titties need
props this guy's yeah what do we said
earlier what do we say only thing worse
than dope beers or what other thing
worse than Warren beers no no
alternative is good hey we do have
Budweiser here uh Cowboy I know
Budweiser if you want some yeah I'll
have a bud that's right uh we're here
but are they cold we got a cold Bud for
cowboy
damn
uh so I gotta slow down on booze I gotta
this fight you got coach Polly or
something
this is the longest I've gone without
smoking weed in a while
are you are you Jones an hour and a half
well you guys we could smoke in here but
you don't have a vape or nothing no I'm
all right bro it's legal I need tobacco
in there dude why you won't be a good
host of them it's legal now it's legal
yeah we're in like a corporate building
look at this ceiling oh you need like a
blunt yeah
I definitely go stand when I don't do it
if you guys want to smoke you can smoke
have you ever done Andrew but what about
this fight that we're realistically not
paying anything
even if UFC fights won't pay attention
you know what I'm saying so this is like
normal normal yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
no it's we it's I don't know you just
pay attention to the main event all
these years of me seeing people do like
fighting opinions I don't know if I ever
watched one I'm gonna be honest with you
no there's three hours if you watch all
your porns and you're just gonna say
that I know I watch all your only fans
in them his wife is hot Jack oh yeah
she's super thank you yeah but that's
why yeah hey have you ever jacked off to
his wife though no you know I'm not I
don't disrespect the man we're about to
get the cowboy review of my [ __ ] on
camera this is amazing oh you've never
seen this girl yeah hey I'm about to
marry her so if if you don't approve
just let me know hey thank you how long
you been with her
six years seven years yeah thinking
about another baby or uh
uh yeah sooner or later you want a boy
don't you yeah just mix it up a little
bit I definitely need to definitely need
a boy
but you know if I end up with a whole
Army of girls it is what it is but you
know it'd be cool to mix it up are you
are you poly we don't [ __ ] anybody
outside of our content thanks oh okay it
is rules to this
a lot of people we you know know in the
industry and stuff have like more open
relationships I just think for me and
her we're like kind of boring besides
when we're doing the pouring like we
don't really go out or anything like I
know a lot of people who have those kind
of relationships where like they can
just [ __ ] whoever before Nah when I met
her because she's never [ __ ] anywhere
besides me through the whole porn thing
you know so when I met her she asked me
like do you think I should make an only
fans or it was Private Snapchat at the
time and I was like I don't care I'm
just [ __ ] you go ahead yeah
we kept getting more and more yeah man
like be positive to your girl she got a
body base you want to do something are
there a lot of couples support that man
you know it's like that I'm about to
about my grand tour I mean of course I
don't know [ __ ] dudes or not but I'm
like baby you wanna you wanna You Wanna
Be sexy like yeah
doing the what's on lingerie
she'll be doing like the lingerie like
the Deluge you know Instagram yeah or
only fans on the only fans should be
doing a little I mean she'd become
posting some I mean she [ __ ] you you
see my girl you'd be like damn
[ __ ]
you're not fooling nobody if my girl
puts up a picture I think is even a
little bit out of there I'm like uh
who's that for I said yeah that's
totally don't play that [ __ ] totally
cool too man that's totally what are you
trying to do Cowboy old school yeah
Colorado
you know so it's just really about how I
mean
yeah I got you I'll give you a bottle
yeah
I've known Cowboys
when I was fighting I don't have a ton
of money he let me stay at his house and
train at Jackson's with him and Leonard
Garcia live together on the ranch no
there's no I bought the ranch yeah I had
a house in Albuquerque before I mean
Cody Donovan came just to training The
Jacksons yeah because at the time
everyone always ask me like at the time
MMA wasn't a big big move like not like
it is now or is MMA gym on every corner
it was a great Jackson or uh Pat
millages were the two camps and I lived
I was in Colorado so Albuquerque was
literally next door and Leonard Garcia
came he was fighting Roger Huerta and he
uh was trained within Colorado and he
said hey come down to Jax with me for a
week and I was like [ __ ] all right I'll
go and I literally went down in the
truck with him and never came in stayed
never never went back
was out the team captain Denver then he
started training at Jackson Cowboy just
after the ultimate fighting when you
went yeah and then I kept going down
there yeah oh even before okay yeah I'd
go down to Jackson's I thought she was a
football player right before the
ultimate fight that's what I always got
two years before oh yeah I was trying I
was I had like did you know we was on
the same reality show really yeah that's
why I met him yeah and he was one of the
on him and Matt matron was on the other
team the only two guys from the other
team that I got along with yeah me
around picture boys
what is it this has been such fun for me
because I just this is so outside of my
world like if you don't know much about
MMA a bunch of Fighters like us yeah
exactly yeah so outside of my world of
like you know the the should be around
no I mean MMA is the best sport in the
[ __ ] world best people too best
people yeah most people rear down Earth
you know what you know why because you
get humble yeah yeah we're we're most
out of all the athletes the famous
athletes we're I think we're the most
humble and we don't have like a big
Entre garage every time we go places
some do now only Conor McGregor and
[ __ ] Ronda Rousey when it takes it
takes a lot of it takes a it takes a lot
of
a lot of I'll say like uh I don't know
what
what is the word I'm looking for like uh
gay
now what is where I'm looking for where
you're like uh primitive like like what
are you doing
ancestral tenants remind me to tell you
about that when you do like you want a
pitch I do where it's like the alpha
male job where you fight each other and
then you can just get up and say hey
today you're a bigger man than me and
then it'd be that like of course like
there's there's no like of course you
guys are almost down to earth beautiful
people because you just do like a primal
gig yeah but you can respect each other
and inspect them the show like nature
will do with a big man
you know yeah yeah you think so I know
so I literally do the opposite thing
that you guys do for them and like I
literally you know you do like [ __ ]
the Primitive man beat each other and
then like love each other but Teddy also
I do literally do the [ __ ] please
validated my emotions I'm an emotional
toddler please someone tell me yeah
like the opposite job but but also a lot
when you're in you know the the
entertainment business like podcast I
mean you go there's some podcasts out
there that are going to but they have
like an open discussion and you're
talking about like transgender earlier
that ain't happening on Jimmy Kimmel you
know what I'm saying like you have three
minutes and then you're gonna sing so
nobody really gets to know you're like
pitching your new album oh yeah sure
yeah it's interesting what is your um
Jimmy Fallon song
what do you mean if you had a right now
if you were going you had to [ __ ] get
up and perform a song what would you do
oh damn uh
Journey
these Journeys Don't Stop Believing them
don't stop it's like the white person
that's a tough one dude that's a tough
one if you can't sing that's a tough one
Journey you [ __ ] with journey Journey's
cool doing a lot of like 80s his cover
his coverage journey is better than the
richest I would never say that I'll say
it for you I always say we do what
what's that what that thing has done to
change my life dog with that thing is
trying to change but I just I just last
week was in San Francisco doing the uh
doing the uh doing the the uh the the
what's the Golden State Warriors
Christmas tree lighting right in front
of dude and Journeys from San Francisco
um they hit me up to go do like it's
it's a Christmas I mean in their
Hometown in San Francisco right in front
of like right in front of Chase Stadium
I'm I'm singing lights Wheel in the Sky
Don't Stop Believing I mean that one
little video that one little video has
turned me into being the guy that
Journey calls when they need a singer is
that Filipino
still still doing his thing like I'm not
gonna because Steve Perry can't the
original uh yeah the original front man
can't sing because his vocal cords yeah
no he had something go on with his
vocals so then they had a kid who was he
was on like this yeah
I was probably a bunch of drugs and you
know what I'm saying but oh Steve Perry
back in the day
you're gonna love it
when I moved to California and I smoke
some weed that [ __ ] was so potent I
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up and none of my
friends would smoke weed this dude my
boy said something about having
Percocets and I just like felt like my
blood chemistry change all of a sudden
where I was just like oh and then I like
my mind snap back to normal it was like
no you can't do that yeah but it's like
it still has that [ __ ] I like them
but you will used to have a problem with
them right you're sober yeah but not
anything too crazy well you you Trump I
mean you were awesome yeah that was
awesome at doing Xanax yeah he's a
really good first team all Pros Xanax
first
I never tried I've never tried people
don't believe that when I say that
you're better never tried yeah me
neither I don't mess with anything I
never tried I never even tried it I
never tried Molly when it was a problem
something changing you know I mean it's
something some people can get away from
like or some people can have an enough
stronger minor get away from it or
finally kick but like once you get that
disease of addiction or you get
something that you're like whoa this
like maybe you never try because maybe
your first time trying could be that
thing that clicks in your brain
chemistry that's like I want this every
day
because you know I grew up in Memphis
and um I don't put my business out there
but um I grew up in the hood and I saw
like people doing cracking [ __ ] yeah
well I think crack's different I know I
know I know crack a different level I
know crack's different but I know it
comes from cocaine right so yeah it is
when I first started smoking weed it
took me six months of studying the
people who was giving it to me I studied
them first people to offered until I
started them first for six months and I
was I was no no no no I'm just weird
like that I was eight I was eight years
old
so it took me six months nah maybe not
that thing's real this thing is
I think that thing's off you almost had
me full for a second when she was bent
over shaking yeah her ass ain't big
enough to be a BBS she would have wasted
enough money but remember I've seen a
lot of bvos that don't look like the way
they're supposed to look oh there's some
messages it falls out and it's sitting
all kinds of weird angles
yeah yo crazy [ __ ] I'm sure you've seen
a lot oh yeah I've seen it all but
remember the hype right now and even
Cowan's getting into it is uh shrooms
yeah I heard Mike Tyson swears by him at
column okay stand mushrooms I can't even
eat food mustard you don't like
mushrooms on your pizza no you get like
mushroom candies and [ __ ] you don't
gotta actually like eat it you can do it
with chocolate
I would definitely agree with the uh the
the micro dogs Logan swears by him oh it
is a thing like it really is a thing you
microdose them in such a way like it's
like .01 of a it won't change your
Chemistry or make a trip or anything
there's a different perspective or just
give you like a a lift of attitude and a
creative energy and it promotes brain
cell growth that is kind of like a it
really is kind of like a really great
[ __ ] but you know guys with guys with
CT PTSD they're uh uh prescribing
shrooms to them now supposed to help I
heard about that I heard about this let
me tell you this my son he's a fighter
now right and he and he was a couple
years ago he was doing like s oh
because I'm not into drugs but it [ __ ]
it [ __ ] him up but did you change him
it's changed him but then I found out
that he um was doing too much yeah
I guess he didn't know how to do it
that's a weird thing for me when people
want to talk about mushrooms and I
realized that they're just like micro
does these little mushroom candies and
I'm like bro like when I was doing
mushrooms we would just [ __ ] get it
all faces [ __ ] yeah have the next 12
hours of your life he's just you going
crazy dude yeah why do that I don't know
in retrospect it wasn't that fun yeah
where I literally like do like every
chance we got opportunity we go [ __ ]
rent a cabin we'd face [ __ ] five six
Grands like and just have a experience
when did the first fate face tats come
along it was that I'm sure so no my uh
my granddad uh who was again was a
Pentecostal Pastor he always used to do
this thing to me you know it was like uh
you know what well you know the colon of
God is without repentance son so uh easy
whatever you do just make sure I mean
you get all these tattoos all this
carrying on you're doing all these rock
bands and stuff son like all this
carrying on but just promise me you're
not gonna get your face tattooed and so
when he passed away
um it's go time my grandma said
something to me that was like well he's
he's home at last and so I got uh home I
left I that was the first one I got just
to kind of which he would hate right
yeah but it was it was in commemoration
that's cool you're just kind of like
like I'm gonna do it but I just got home
at last because my grandma said to after
he died and yeah and so it's kind of
like to commemorate him to do he was a
he's what you think he's well he's also
a great [ __ ] great [ __ ] person you
know but uh so it was it was just kind
of my like last ditch effort to like
make him roll over in his grave one more
time and be like he'd probably
appreciate it yeah yeah oh my God Heaven
exists you better whip my ass and get up
there big boy you know what I mean no
these boys it's a slobber
yeah that's why these are fun you know
it's chaos dude you don't know if Heaven
exists you don't know huh I'm nobody
knows I don't think anybody I I I would
always say dude I do appreciate the the
principles and the and the work ethic
and the love that like he like the the
way that I was raised uh there's
definitely so much I take from the the
perspectives of like how to treat human
beings but
um
and also know how to have like a strong
enough Foundation that like
you're right no matter what but my
granddad always did this thing where
like if you didn't believe everything
how he believed it the way he believed
it then you was wrong yeah and that was
something about me that I just never
really did Vibe with I didn't Vibe with
but I do I don't also know that like
like it gave me like what I want to do
for a living what I do for a living is
like yo I know exactly what my purpose
is and I followed it and I pursued it
with everything in me so like I knew I
was right no matter what but also I just
can't I just can't be that stronger I'm
like everybody else is [ __ ] wrong
except me that's what happens
you know I'll tell you what I I don't
like um is that guy's shorts on the
right
well two you know they got their cups
I guess his is black you know that's why
I don't look right though I'm telling
you that's why I don't look right the
whole thing's awkward that guy's jacked
up he's literally the same so I I agree
with it
but you can sing you do no right here
right here with the same I think we got
the same shorts though those shirts are
pretty aggressive
how long are they gonna make for us to
wait to figure this out the the judges
don't know what the hell they're doing I
bet they're like I don't know how to
score this goddamn thing they both got
punched in the face I might say I agree
with uh thick boy Schwab a lot of people
don't know
because you know we've been taught
Heaven is made out of drugs all right so
we we we're we're like smart even though
humans we're sheep I'm gonna say that we
are I'm gonna tell you that yeah I'm a
wolf I have to say that part but we
don't know we've been taught that heaven
is made out of gold and all this stuff
and then then then another thing that
there's space there's outer space we
don't see we don't see that so yeah I
mean you guys
no [ __ ] that but what is it myself
oh no no I'm just kidding all I know is
the show like all I know is for show is
like that like go if if there is if
there is something that like like if
there's if there's a Buddhist monk who
like declares like 40 years of Silence
has never [ __ ] a woman in his life
then he's damn show more of a Buddhist
than I've ever been aggression more than
my granddad's ever been together
what I'm saying what I'm
what I'm saying is what I'm saying is I
can't I damn sure ain't fitting to look
at that [ __ ] telling me it's
wrong you know I damn sure ain't gonna
tell me he's right because you gotta
[ __ ] you you know what I'm saying yeah
I damn sure ain't gonna tell nobody they
wrong especially if they come with some
like do one thing about me like I know
exactly what I want what I think is
right in the world and who I am is
exactly right and I would not even
entertain the fight of being wrong you
will never be able to tell me I'm wrong
but also if you write about something I
could I could say all right you ain't
wrong but you better come matching that
same [ __ ] energy listen to
somebody that's [ __ ] a 50 year old
version you would listen to him
we're meant to
meant to [ __ ] we're listening to that
guy and he'll be in heaven
that's his point of view but we're meant
to [ __ ] well we're headed right now even
in that even in that Bible not me baby
well yeah well can you put in a good
word for me do even in that Bible dog
even in that Bible it says it says you
have to find a good woman it's like
rubies but it also says dude Paul says
this I think it might be Romans so he
says Paul says yo if you can make it
through like life without like having to
like have like if without having to have
a woman like it literally says like your
purpose will be like more like fulfilled
this is paraphrasing I can find I can
find it and put it but
so like how much is a point the point
the point that it says if you can't if
you can't control yourself and you gotta
[ __ ] you better marry that one yeah yeah
you know but I mean it'll leave it'll
even tell you like yeah that's also the
Bible telling you don't want to spread
disease for mankind you know what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying it's all
it's all all of it's good yeah I'm gonna
tell you my understanding everybody
don't agree with the same thing but my
understanding is that some religions are
too strict on some things that they say
is wrong or sin which really isn't and
I'm just gonna leave it there and
nothing I'm gonna tell you is
I know you you're not an evil person no
not at all so you don't gotta you don't
gotta say like where I'm going is hot oh
no I'm just joking I know you're joking
okay I just want to let you know I don't
think but okay so me saying that I think
a religion like remember I told y'all
earlier that I don't want to um be
prejudiced against people like so I'm
not president because it's all different
religions yeah but so I feel like
basically the most high has no religion
they're the religion is man-made so a
lot of religions put a lot of stuff on
us and this make us feel guilty which
are we not supposed to that's that's
exactly like saying I grew up Christian
I'm from the Bible Belt like it's it's a
sin to go to the club it's not a sin to
go to a nightclub unless you're seeing a
drink it's not a scene when they wrote
those bugs whatever you know whatever is
your Bible there were no strips
I'm just saying but they wrote it those
both just three thousand years ago
there's no strip clubs
they change the rules a little bit
that's all I'm saying
yeah she's working for you your [ __ ]
working for you I ain't gonna tell you
you're wrong ever your [ __ ] just yeah I
hope your [ __ ] worked for you there's no
Magic City man like I'm gonna tell you
what I ain't you know I'll tell you what
I ain't I'm gonna tell you what I am but
if you if your [ __ ] worked for you I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell them I
hope it God damn work I can say this way
when I came save me some stress when I
became definitely not to try to convert
you to what my [ __ ] is [ __ ] hell no I
ain't gonna do that I like I know it's
working for me and I could I can I can
probably give you some advice it might
all I can give you is what's working for
me and if it works for you these girls
have the best technique of the Night by
the way so I'm gonna say I'm a goddamn
Christian tonight the girl the girl
girls
go smoke brother oh my baby supposed to
be sick hey the girl take a piss do your
thing we'll hold it down the girl the
girl in the girl in the red though I was
smashed though I was smashing girl in
the red I like um
I didn't see the girl in a white guy
yeah she's they're both cute by far have
the best technique I like girls with big
noses that is that wrong nah man you
like your big beak on them yeah hell
yeah that's that wrong not at all
something wrong with nothing wrong with
big bees I don't judge you dude I was
dating this Persian girl for for a while
she had like a pterodactyl nose [ __ ]
yeah and I loved it wow you like the big
no you like how it smash it in your face
when you make out no it's not gonna like
you did that here let me get that lip
suck on it I like the way it rubbed
against my nuts though if I could say oh
God
by far the most technical fight of the
night yeah by far oh and there's another
one there's two girls there's another
girl fight yeah Savage beautiful Bobby
Joe
95 pounds the other girl's 90 pounds
four seven and four ninety five pounds I
bet you they are they're four
people wow they don't look small do they
no they don't know wow four seven what's
the what's the cutoff for a small person
uh I think if you're I think four eleven
and under could considered small right
chin yeah he's Googling right now bring
it up I can't smash it goes 95 pounds
what'd you say how you ever want to date
it up have you ever wanted to date a
fighter chick fourteen can you consider
small person
uh I mean somewhere especially now
somewhere I mean like Paige man's dance
man you got you got a bunch of yeah
she's not bad there's a bunch of baddies
out there yeah she's not bad yet when we
were fighting I mean Cowboy finally
looked like warlocks it was you know hey
we had a different time we had Gina we
had Gina when we was fighting Gina was
she retired by the time I got around to
it no she was Gina was the hottest
fighter ever
she was also like that you know she was
the Pioneer
um she's a good actors too she's
beautiful she's yeah she's so pretty
cool too she got a good person she's
cool people yeah she's cool really cool
people they went after her hard right
they tried cancer yeah
so stupid that was so stupid I stopped I
stopped watching that [ __ ] um show
she was in when she oh the Mandalorian
or whatever the Stars you should have
been watching the first place but it was
good I watched good I support MMA
fighters I I have a lot of respect for
you because you know her parents own
Caesar's Palace I didn't know that what
I thought then her dad play for the
Dallas Cowboys too yeah but they uh they
don't Caesar's Palace oh she rich rich
yeah I didn't know that and she wanted
to be a kickboxer that's the [ __ ] you
money yeah they have they had casinos in
Reno and they just they just recently
bought Caesars here in Vegas wow good
for her yeah so uh
she's a go-getter though yeah she oh
she's a badass so I have so much she set
the path for a lot of Fighters go when
she's like working yeah man or woman
she's at the path I mean she was the
first one kind of break out just doing
her thing and she's gorgeous too
yeah that's why Rhonda has so much
respect for him so Rhonda said that she
was like if there's one fight I would
take it'd be you know if Gina would come
out of retirement Gina was like man I'm
not trying to cut wait Gina would have
[ __ ] her up though I'm I don't
normally pick I don't know I vintage
Gina now no I don't know listen now
Ronda Rousey and Jenna if they fight
right today Jenna will [ __ ] her up no
Corona Ross has been doing pro wrestling
she ain't been training for fighting and
training either she's doing movie I know
at least Ronald is doing some form of
combat but I bet you didn't would [ __ ]
her up I would bet you money oh I bet on
that all day I would bet you all day on
that one because because obviously the
stand-up would be an issue for Rhonda
but when it hits the ground when she
does that Judo toss
does Gina have much Jiu Jitsu I don't
know no her takedown defense is pretty
good but especially when she was
fighting there wasn't that like there
wasn't a ton of you know variety dude
but she was the original battle so what
she did for Strike Force her and Kimbo
yeah they're the face of it yeah
much respect to Gina always you know
Gina didn't have that many fights she
didn't have it let's fight when she
fought cyborg she was actually doing
really well in that fight cyborg was
just a [ __ ] animal well Gina was 7-0
before cyborg yeah oh yeah Superstar
they shouldn't even put it against
cyborg I'll be honest like is he the
cash cow I put against cyborg yeah
because Gina had the entire package with
the books that you'd speak well and then
you know I love cyborg she trains with
the same coach I trans okay
she comes with Mickey I'm gonna tell
y'all something McKee is a sleeper he's
the best coach ever oh his son's the
champ yes well he was but he's stuck I I
feel like he got robbed but okay yeah
I'm with you yeah but his son yeah his
son is one of the best I've seen the
song I've been on the sun since he was
three years old yeah I've seen the son
in the gym what's that gym called power
is it uh Body Shop body shop that's
right I thought I got out of there Chase
Gormley back in the day yeah yeah my
first UFC fight you beat him yeah 50
seconds yeah yeah but we'll just ask hey
but I'm gonna tell you the key is the
best coach so cute oh he's a great coach
because he knows you know he's been in
there he knows that his son grew up with
all you guys yeah his son knows the game
we I had a son on Food Truck Yeah
sometime yeah he's cool he's cool yeah
he's really good he's I think I think if
you keep going he's the future of the
sport I think he'd be like I think he's
gonna come over to the UFC I guess he's
not he I think he wants to we talked
about on the show everybody wants to
everybody listen I know Bellator pain
what won Championship or not one shot
but one championship's legit does he
come but like when it comes to Bellator
and like pfl yeah
everybody
go out front we're going like through a
side door oh okay but like my son my son
is fighting my son's undefeated right
now and amateur though right hold up hey
fellas
I'll just tell you from The Listener
standpoint where as we drink more too we
got to make sure we're not having two
different conversations yeah my bad
because I'm I'm lit right now
tiger thick
can I say I don't like the name but I
like the tree yeah you like Rogan don't
like the name Rogan don't like the name
he was like I love the whiskey don't
like the name I was like well we're
Rogan is smart well not when it comes to
marketing if it was stand up or you know
or business-wise I'll listen but Mark
and I'll I'll take you from here at the
end of the day I'm gonna say I like I
love Joe I like you more than I like
Rogan because Rogan Rogan never invited
me on this show and you invited me twice
never been on never been on wrong have
you ever asked to be on I had this
conversation with Mark hunt the other
day I was at Irwin and I hear job I'm
going to get my breakfast here and Mark
hunt looks over and I look forward kind
of like what yeah I was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing out here and here's
that lawsuit with the UFC I'm out here
my boys are out here he said I'm heading
to Vegas like dancing going on seven
years done I didn't post a picture to
him the picture his buddy took the
picture is awful what's the lawsuit I'm
never asked to be on any any interview I
never well then why would Rogan have you
on if you never asked well I don't know
I don't know how to say work but I'm
just gonna hear this and definitely no
no no but why would I I don't know
interview I never asked to be on anybody
but I don't think people understand like
with Rogan's schedule and the guy who
booked it Matt it's like uh he's booked
like eight months out it's nuts and the
amount of people that has to be on the
show is insane when it comes to Fighters
and I know we respect you like you're a
legend you'd have you on the heart no
I'm not mad somewhere yeah you drop him
yeah I'm not I'm not mad at nothing I
just never actually be on there and I so
I've never been on it yeah yeah so is
that how it work you got to ask people
to be on their podcast no I don't think
so I don't know well how did all you
guys get here today I'm friends I'm
friends with him so yeah I'm friends man
he's one of my favorites and I've been
wanting to get Adam on for a while yeah
and then really this got put together
Rampage was the only originally because
original associate Theo and Joey Diaz in
Rampage and then uh damn I want to meet
Joe would do this Joey's the best so
Joey's supposed to come out but then his
book came out he's like dude he's
supposed to do a whole like thing out
here in California
and he was like yeah and he was like I'm
out he's like I he's like I gotta I
guess he has to be in New York for his
book or something like that he's like
I'm on the next one I can't make this
one like all good week goes by was it a
day ago Theo said he was like he's gonna
be tough but put me on the flyer promote
me I should be able to make it and then
yesterday was like I can't do it and
then that's when I hit up everybody
I know to be fair he was like I'm damn
dude I'd love to do it he's like I don't
know if I'm in town but put him on the
flyer I should be able to do it no no if
you if you test him I put you on the Fly
I'm sorry I don't give a [ __ ] who I said
to his face yeah somebody put you on a
[ __ ] phone it puts me in a tough
tight spot you know what I'm saying you
just got this just this type of person I
am well but then the problem was and
then he didn't like being put on a fly
no no
yeah homeboy got blasted off the bat one
of the guys that said Wanna Be Tick Tock
star when he was walking out that's
exactly what he looks like too he looks
like a little fake Bryce Hall
the kid with the beaver cut he got
blasted
what can I say it I'm just glad to if it
was Joey Diaz and Theo Vaughn and I was
the second call I'd glad to be the
second call to those guys any [ __ ]
day of the week yo the other guy that
said your average Kebab guy
like that's actually what it said under
his name
oh we have the small person fighting
next with the the beautiful Bobby Joe 95
pounds and Savage Sadie wait so what
fight are we on man I did not even
yeah they do a bunch of them because
they're only three one minute rounds so
they fly through them and there's a guy
coming up named I eat ass that's a good
question I'm trying to figure it out
because hold on let's see the faces it's
a little Tick Tock looking at this guy
well there's only 45 minutes left
guy yeah your average Kebab guy is what
his name is bildo so it's not racist
when I say that even though it sounds
very racist in the corner a little butt
shot oh well that's not a little guy
right that's a woman that's a woman oh
she's getting ready to go uh oh she
better fight no I think she's a ring car
girl she's probably cold so she put
those uh sweats on between maybe but why
would they why would they oh there she
is just twerking you know when you are
watching the UFC and you look at the
ring girls and you're like damn they're
so hot those girls would never let me
[ __ ] this is not giving me that energy
nothing would hurt me more than if I was
fighting and I wanted to be respected
for that and then there was a woman with
her ass half out that they put in the
corner just to say in case you're not
having fun watching this look at this
woman just standing here with her ass
out yeah I'm with you teddy but I don't
think these people want a career in
fighting
it's like organized World Star Hip-Hop
fights yeah you know it's like
if you have 20 000 followers and you
want to fight some other guy with 20 000
followers we have a home for you we are
Barstool Sports
there's got to be like a battle story
from most of these dudes
that's the uh dude there's one guy after
the small prison fight his name is I eat
ass yeah yeah yeah three in one let's
find a guy named I wonder if he eats us
yeah it has to right he looks like he
does do they give much time to train for
this or I don't well they announceable
these guys look like they definitely
like they look like they're somewhat
trained and I wonder what his Camp was
like yeah they're at least trading
enough
a lot of Kebabs yeah we already know
but some of these guys look like they
actually have like trained a little bit
in their life yeah some of them did the
heavyweights the the main event once you
get towards there that that guy I think
he has like six or seven fights like you
can tell he's in a gym training yeah but
the girls they look like they trained
yeah those girls like those girls by far
the best if you get tired of one minute
rounds bro it's just an experience too
like I mean I know the difference
between like a you know at least enough
of a difference between like a like a
hot like a high school slap box and
fight in the bathroom versus like you
know like a well you know at least
somebody trained a little bit go ahead
reminds would you fellas ever did you
see Dana White's new uh slap I heard
about content like League you just get
slapped I heard about that it's just
slapping yes it's just that [ __ ] where
you're standing from yeah like we
started a league of just that Dana did
something
it's getting big and they make some
money dude I just recently on Twitter
man I met this guy we started talking on
uh because I was watching like somebody
we started talking on Instagram and I I
brought him out to I think it was one of
our shows in like New York I remember
where it was I talked to this guy all
the time he he just goes by slap for
cash on Instagram and he's dude this
dude is I mean like like you like like
jelly roll big like bro like but his
hands bro I ain't telling you like God
damn his hands is like he's made the
slap dude what's his name the slap and
that [ __ ] what he does let's
just go viral off of like slop he stands
across the table like this and me and
you like we slapped each other back and
forth that [ __ ] knocks people
gold oh yeah like he's slaps he slap you
and but what makes you against you but
like you know what I'm saying like I
guess you gotta have a good goal if you
get knocked out
unless you knock him out the first slap
but you don't know the rules
absolutely not my daddy was a slapper
I'm a slapper my son will be a slapper
life's too good yeah I mean that's going
life's too good to do a three million
dollar a slap fight yeah he's done with
the head trunk you know I feel like it's
crazy to fate with that [ __ ] yeah we're
Fighters what we're fighting what he's
telling me is that he got at least 20
million in the bank yeah I'm not I'm not
in three minutes we're Fighters that's
what we that's what he's telling me when
I asked him three three million dollars
slap fight he said no oh he's he's
telling me he got at least 20 million
I'm [ __ ] a dude live on TV for three
minutes
you got 500 Acres Cowboy you're the the
John Dutton of fighting bro that means a
[ __ ] done coming out of cowboys mouth
I'll tell you that goddamn money if
anybody ever spent some bars in their
life
for an hour
Acres yeah
see that
anybody talk to you there's a price on
something God damn that's [ __ ] me up
okay Cowboy had one button that's weird
but you know he won't take his lap for
three minutes yeah no no no he had one
butt but one one Budweiser and Kelly and
loose you would do it Rampage you would
do the side fighting for a million
dollars one meal one meal I'll do it for
one meal I don't got 20 million in the
bank I do for free but you know look
dude at least if if you're in like the
fighting like y'all do like you know
adrenaline pumping and you know like
whatever shots that get taken that you
like every shot you eat is like
something that you his name is the
average you could have you could have
avoided but if you were like UFC you're
going in there thinking like well at
least there's a chance I'm not gonna get
hit in the [ __ ] head during that
that's right exactly what I'm doing
standing in front of someone and just
letting them that's what I'm saying you
better take one I don't know and give
one take one get like no like you're
walking in there without your adrenaline
pumping knowing I'm about to get [ __ ]
but this is the secret about me about my
fighting Carissa says I never cared if I
got [ __ ] up
that's one thing yeah
I never cared if I got need
face
punch I never I never gave a [ __ ] about
myself growing up the way my family
treated me and the way I grew up I never
gave a [ __ ] so somebody stabbing me for
a million dollars okay yeah but so what
would you say would you say if you never
gave a [ __ ] about losing or getting your
ass bit or whatever would you say that
your training has been more to prevent
getting your ass whooped or to whoop ass
I think I got the best defense in MMA
so you could you could say that as a
fighter that's like I don't care if I
get my ass whooped but you you're a
major you're you're training off of okay
avoiding he accepted the possibility
but then everyone can sit here and say
you have to but they could sit here and
say dude off of trying to do everything
I can to not let that happen right I can
also accept that that's a fate yeah
right at the end of the day he wants to
be on only stands at the end of the day
I'm not going to help somebody whoop my
ass right so I I don't care if I got hit
punches but I'm not gonna let them you
know what I'm saying well that's that's
the thing about that slap fighting this
it's weird for me it's like dude I gotta
let them though you gotta let them yeah
bro if you oh yeah I mean I could I
could use it I could use big babies too
like regular people yeah because there's
like showing TLC small people a big
world and the the dude is with a normal
sized lady and they have a baby in the
kid's normal size yeah yeah but the dude
dude my dude my my best friends is that
dude they're my best friends that dude
uh so my buddy awesome I went to high
school he's a small person yeah dude in
my best [ __ ] it so this kid Austin all
her he's got his wife is also a little
person Janae and they just recently
she's about to be one years old
um Regular Size oh wow yeah you didn't
know that no I didn't I thought they
gave birth to uh regular size and she's
pregnant again and it's looking even
more like she they gonna have another
regular size yeah how does that work
when you're the dad you're like oh boy
I'll whip your ass the kids like eight
like [ __ ] [ __ ] dad he's a union
dude so how do you how do you have a you
have a car that's set up for you yeah
that and then you have a house that's
set up for that and then you know when
you got a two-year-old kid that starts
climbing yeah they ain't even got to do
that there's a little bit they could
just reach the freezer like yeah that's
a crazy life though anyone want to take
any you you were you're one to know you
haven't picked since the first fight you
go beautiful y'all haven't picked you
want me to pick yeah please I'm taking
beautiful and I'm telling you beautiful
they're both beautiful and Savage
they're both very pretty how tall are
they uh four four seven and four four
ones I take it on the black shorts I
don't know nothing about you're taking
Savage Sadie these are actual little
people they're like a little bit littler
than average people but they're not
full-blown dwarfs well they they said
that we I Googled that because of the
question 411 is the state yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I dated a little person then God damn
you dated a four 11 girl oh she was Tiny
I thought it's like two Siamese fish oh
the girl your girl almost gave up yeah
you just walked away she wasn't that
damn short though yo what windmill
windmill the technique not great but
they're
feature fans got the littlest short
Tyrannosaurus Rex arms bro yeah
that's what they call it I'm guessing
it's her like only fans type like
sponsor it's probably like only videos
right or like a joke because they've
been doing joke stuff but they said it
said wants to be on only stands that's
like only Fans Bar Stool podcast you
know oh words I don't
but uh beautiful Bobby Joe I feel like
he's Landing better shots I was on only
fans briefly when they was trying to go
like more mainstream what were you doing
showing it
I know it was nothing
trying to get my fat ass in shape chain
his [ __ ] so okay so let's get in shape
let's say this you'll get this so let's
say this you get the [ __ ] slapped out of
you for a million dollars and that's all
right but you spread your [ __ ] and
only fans around yeah I co-signed that
yeah
damn near you do it for a mill oh yeah
I'll bend over the table and moon the
whole yeah now that girl's eating my ass
on only fans and felt gas [ __ ] doing it
but is the camera on your face though no
I'm okay
I'm sitting here oh you're like a baby
girl's right up doing the stinky leg
you're just feeling like a total
F slur no you don't know
it's only a cuck if you put both legs up
like a baby I don't know that day I was
trying to find out I'm not letting him
put a finger in there
dude I got I got dude I literally got
the same thing man where I'm like so
uncomfortable with my I mean I'll be the
first to toss a salad on a bit like I
eat a woman's ass any day but like I do
not like dude even some of my homies
Teddy got a hairy ass dude oh God I can
I know dude how you know also why the
[ __ ] why would the [ __ ] you also want to
flirt with our shame and [ __ ] like and
so some of my boys too you tell me that
oh you let a girl you got a girl eat
your ass it feels so good like bro it
ain't yeah like you let a girl eat your
ass it feels so good you should really
try it yeah
I can't I can't she uh she she
afterwards like had a real disappointed
look on her face and she was just like
Adam you should shave your [ __ ] yeah
she was just like she was actually like
she's disgusted yeah
and asked you should know we have hairy
[ __ ] it sounds like she didn't have
a good I think a lot of the male porn
star dudes keep their [ __ ] behaved
you know especially dude because like I
said I got a couple buddies that have
tried to convince me to get my ass away
because it's like the best [ __ ] ever
give it a go no it's like you don't
respect no it's like Fight Club you you
can sit here and say how uncomfortable
it makes you feel could you at least
tell me you don't feel uncomfortable
that I was on camera with my leg up I
got my ass eaten by my girl sometimes
and it's like whatever but just having
my legs so weird is it totally like is
it is it enough to like be like feel
weird about like does it feel good
enough to feel weird about it
I've seen too is that if you are like
stone cold sober for me at least
it's kind of like tickless when she
first starts getting going and then once
she's like she starts really doing it
then it kind of feels normal but at
first I'm like I'm like jumping away
yeah when she's teeth deep in that ass
yeah you get your ass ate yeah to me
it's like Fight Club first rule of ass
eating Club you don't talk about it
what is it is I mean let's talk about it
bro because I like
to tell you I'm not comfortable about it
that's why I'm trying because like so
many of my home is just like no bro no
bro like you should try it like serious
you know and then I also I know I'm
gonna I'm in a relationship like where
obviously I don't think my girl would
love to eat my ass but she totally would
yeah if I was trying to get you if I was
trying to like give myself over to my
[ __ ] ass eating virginity to somebody
it would totally be her but you know my
boys no she doesn't at all I mean I
don't want her to and I don't think she
would would you kiss her did she did you
kiss the girl did you ate your ass no no
it's just you kiss your girl if it's
your girl it's just disrespectful a
little bit right it's like I haven't at
least I don't think I haven't even I
haven't even gotten I haven't even
gotten that far far in the thought it's
like if she ate my ass don't even think
about that
boy is really quiet doing his ass eating
I think y'all was like no I want to know
dude I have like such a dude I have such
a thing even even when he's like so when
I was living with my boys and you know
the whole [ __ ] pandemic first started
and everybody's running out of toilet
paper you had roommate study and we had
got we had gotten this like we had
gotten that that bidet thing so we could
like and I still like to this day they
like but it was so good at cleaning it
so well it's like not that bad and I I
am so uncomfortable with my [ __ ] like
boy I wouldn't I still haven't even used
it no judgment anybody has but it'd
probably be great
like I wouldn't even use it for today
using the day is not a sexual thing no I
know it's a cleaning thing I'm just
telling you I'm sorry
you're real sensitive with your [ __ ]
but it sounds like your roommates aren't
Teddy because they want you to use the
bidet and then they're talking about
getting your ass lit yeah well they're
just like your boys are gonna try it
they're like you should just not let
life pass you by like if a woman eats
you [ __ ] it's really amazing and you
should try it and I as as it do it while
you're single though because when I
don't want the mother of your kids
eating your ass
damn good like
you'll be such a squid hey you know a
lot about you know a lot about that for
you to be like so secretive about it you
know a lot about no I'm not mad when I
was seeing a lot of weather girl put my
legs up like a baby you want to talk
about you felt weird I was like but it
does feel weird saying about your wife
right
she has to wake up with the kids all I
want to know is am I am I missing out on
like is it something that I need to do
that bad I think no you have no I think
you're good you have what does it feel
does it feels so [ __ ] good so you
don't have to have this conversation
again
yes you can try it out no I don't want
to try it out you're going to be talking
about how you've never done it for the
rest of your life if you don't do it
okay Cowboy meth one time in my life but
every time we ever mention meth on the
show I got something to talk about I
only did it one time it was one weekend
really meth yeah you literally have some
one-liners that are just like changing
my entire like yeah yeah I mean maybe
that's not that big a joke tons of
people have done this on your eye on
meth is that the weekend no there's no
tattoos that weekend but I pretty much
was just up for like two days straight
just [ __ ] I know it's like skydiving
me I'm just never gonna be curious about
it a girl I'm never going to be curious
about skydiving no matter how many
people tell me it's amazing what
conversation at a time fellas don't give
a [ __ ] I'm sorry no girl it was me no go
ahead
it would feel so good that I'd need to
at least I'm never going to know unless
you do it well this guy's name if it's I
could I can ask somebody who's gotten
the dog this is amazing that I should
you gotta try it out you don't don't
knock it till you try it uh Murda Blanca
is fighting I eat ass
if you told me this guy dive I don't
care how amazing it was that's Blanca
and he's melting it's cool we're going
to Tequila now no I only drink whiskey
the ice because this ice in here this I
eat ass on his chest look at this guy
you want to drink your whiskey now no
I'm on the road be honest no I like
being in control bro you know look it
says Joe Rogan Elon Musk and Dave porno
eat ass too a lot of plants I wonder if
Dave signed off on them
Joe Rogan sues for defamation yeah
I don't like broke I mean there's no
rookie right now
why they say that about it
being in control of my [ __ ] right that
Casey Daley's asked for sure snake
game's ass
they're listening to our podcast right
now the commentators
no I doubt it they're watching like a
replacement commentator yes type thing
Joe Rogan eats ass on his back
it's 20 22. I said this guy's just
trying to get attention a lot of people
eating ass now it's like a big thing now
oh yeah yeah
2017. ever since 2017. I feel like 2017
was when asking how to it's if you were
to look at the Google search trends for
eating ass I feel like 2017 eating ass
was at its all-time
big tongue yeah pink eye when when did
that song come out when the girl said
you got to eat the grocery eat the Booty
Like Girls oh yeah when was this you
know when that song come out all right
yeah when that song came out that's why
I felt like the [ __ ] got like Peak ass
eating those Peak ass yeah eating season
that's when all her like 11 year old
fans found out what'd you say like when
she said that all Nicki Minaj's like 11
year old fans found out about anything
yeah
I can say this though I could say this a
lot of girls eat ass but they don't
talk about it no it's Fight Club rules
dude ass eating you don't for girls guys
yeah what year was that it was 20 20.
but to be fair that's what we're talking
about that's her talking about getting
her ass eaten which is a lot less gross
right right when I it was way later in
my life before I even realized that a
guy would ever get his ass eaten by a
chick you know I grew up not knowing
used to wrap up about suck my nuts suck
my nuts lick my butt lick my butt when I
was a kid I was like dude they're
Pioneers they was talking about this
[ __ ] when I was a kid you know I'm 44
now they told me that [ __ ] when I was
like 11 years old
and that's not awesome
I don't want to imagine that oh man
I don't let go down in the [ __ ] life
right but they're not in the hood like
that's what I'm saying but that's what
they was rapping about when I was a kid
Trick Daddy did an interview and he's
like I'll open my legs like Lamborghini
doors I like getting my ass licked I'm
like bro it's Fight Club rules like
Lamborghini doors wow I don't know I'll
be the first to say anybody for whatever
they do but one thing I know is like
even my boys are telling me to get my
essay I'm like yeah yeah we ain't coming
from the gutter though like yeah but
that ain't that ain't what you can't let
your boys tell you you gotta let a girl
tell you that's rich what is this is not
what you're doing you get money and then
you start getting your ass you don't get
your ass ate in the hood like you just
don't [ __ ] do that I'm just telling
you what I'm just telling you what the
rap songs was when I was growing up I'm
telling my boy the Cowboys disgusted and
he's in Hollywood now he can't be
talking about that he can't say that
[ __ ] because he already he already
admitted that he got his ass ate once he
tried it at least
because you know he's you know he's a
man Cowboys the John Dutton of New
Mexico you guys want to talk about
eating ass I know all I know it's got
Cowboys got some wisdom for me about
getting his ass hey I did not need it I
don't know if we can do this afterwards
you got something to be too quiet about
this you got something to give me that
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go here though
raise your hand if a girl ever tried to
put the finger in there
they tried they didn't get in there you
got to stop you got to stop them I had a
doctor go knuckle deep no no doctor's
different that's different yes I was
even there for the checkup oh yeah
uh tonsil deep with their tongue I'm not
talking about that you'll let them go
over there
put his tongue in your ass huh would you
let a doctor put his tongue in your
female doctor and you said heels but
it's part of a medical procedure
that's the magic word right there yes
talking about this earlier when you get
a certain age you got to get your
prostate check yes and it's when that
sucks yes you ain't even 50 yet 39. you
ain't 50. you ain't he went pretty much
sure I went premature too I had a
diarrhea like a lot and they they told
me that they wanted to check out what
was going on
yeah the worst part was not eating for
24 hours before it mm-hmm but it was
worse than having a man finger up your
ass honestly like the way I felt from
just not eating from that long at that
point
I did the same thing I was a male dog
male doctor there's never a baby he put
two fingers he put three and he had
thick sausage no I saw it it was like
Shane Carwin
no I promise three fingers well I was
even there for it three it was just an
overall health check he just wanted to
make sure you felt good I said enjoy
that chocolate on your glove dog
that is not a health check that was a
rape he full of [ __ ] yeah
right there my brother yeah if I ever
had when I turned 50 I'm I have to go do
it for the prostate cancer right yeah
yeah I'm gonna have to choose it like a
little female doctor with small fingers
I'm gonna have to they didn't let me
choose myself
ah Michelle Wang yeah yeah
sounds small Bruce gigantic man no I
don't know why you yeah female name you
wouldn't get the IE ass guy you want to
let him do it
okay but if you had to get your next one
hey you got to get your colonoscopy from
Elon Musk Joe Rogan or Dave Portnoy I'm
not around I'm guessing colon cancer I'm
letting Rogan doing hopefully make a bit
about it
I want to go to my grade
saying knowing no man no doctorate no
male person I want that on your
Tombstone yeah never got fingered by a
man thank you yeah never got diddled by
a man yeah
what is that look at anal never got
figured by a man that's awesome
it's perfect timing for this shirt
with Bradley Cooper I did this movie
called it sounded like a porno but it's
not it's called Uh 18 right no the first
move I did with him was called Midnight
Meat Train Midnight Meat
trainor.com yeah yeah I had a small role
I was like uh back in back in the 70s
there was like a 70s that was like a um
a person that used to walk on the subway
to protect like the women because a lot
of women
is it the Good Samaritans yeah they have
something like that angel so I played
their character yeah the guardian angel
yeah yeah yeah how about that I just
remember hearing about this big in New
York yeah
I was one that's protected in the movie
right yeah and it was called Midnight
Meat Train so what it was that that the
the villain or whatever they used to
kill people and hang them up on this
yeah and stuff like that oh [ __ ] they
looked at that [ __ ] up Cloud demon Dale
Casey yeah that's the one that's the
first one I did with uh Bradley Cooper
right I wonder if Joe Rogan will ever
find out about that and so they had so I
died in them but I got shot whatever and
they had to put me on the meat hook they
had to show my body hanging upside down
the meat hook and it was like
um we gotta plaster your whole body uh
you want to wear a g-string I was like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] no no no I was like I wear a jock
strap I'm used to jockstrap he said no
you're going to want to G you want to
you're going on a g string I'm like
listen bro I want to go to my grave
saying I've never won g string before I
said that on your tune as well yeah I
want to tell you this after they
plastered my body like man this guy was
super homophobic I was I wasn't
homophobic stream yeah one day your kids
are going to be at your [ __ ] grave
just look you never wore a g-string
that's right you never got a few that's
right my kid my boy
my two older boys for sure no ass ever
entered his ass my two older boys are
Superman they they agree with a lot of
[ __ ] I said and hopefully but I'ma tell
you this I'm gonna tell them I'll tell
this in front of my boys I wish I would
have wore g-string that day because they
they plastered one regret my one regret
because they placed in my body with the
jump with the jock strap on you know you
ever wore a drop shot before yeah yeah
yo yo your ass is all open yeah and they
plastered my [ __ ] hole my whole body
and when you pull at the place it had
the [ __ ] imprint of my [ __ ] oh yeah
had that brown eyes yeah they had the
[ __ ] photos
yeah it was an [ __ ] faucer bro I wish
I would have wanted centipede yeah
but you didn't and you could still carry
that [ __ ] to the Grave
I can see a character to the grave but I
can't care to the Grave that somebody
got it they still have it they don't
throw this [ __ ] away they still got an
imprint of my [ __ ] somewhere in
Hollywood one thing about the
Jacksonville what the [ __ ] you laughing
at hopefully it doesn't leak if it leaks
are you gonna be embarrassed [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't care about
nobody's in my [ __ ] along their
finger ain't going in I'll tell you
right now one thing I've known rampant
for a while they pressing my whole body
because because they was going to hang
my body from a hook like a fake body and
then yeah
he's too big to hang yeah but I was like
this poor dude first stone cold knockout
was that the first round he has no idea
what happened first 30 seconds probably
that was like 12 like 20 seconds lit up
uh Diamond hands right Diamond hands
beat up the Assassin king that's
diamonds right there part of the day yes
Diamond hands you smacked my ass oh yeah
another girl fight next I almost got in
a fight
the one thing we've learned about
Rampage is so what do you mean about
plastic like it's a plastic like they
got a like a mold of your body basically
faster that they put yeah you had that
plaster yeah I know you're talking about
they do like a mold of your body so they
don't have to use the real thing to hang
oh [ __ ] body so it wasn't you hanging
it was like just a like a like I guess
like a wax version of you or something
basically yeah and the guy when he was
putting plastic on me they smacked my
ass bro I felt so degraded oh here's the
knockout though if you missed it here's
the knockout nobody saw your [ __ ]
they just saw a boom boom Blaster
version
boom boom
the people that was doing it didn't see
my [ __ ]
but when they put a flash off they did
okay it went everywhere there's an
imprint of his if you find a little bit
of plaster in your [ __ ] later
yeah
look drums there's one thing about the
Jackson family
it was my favorite one until like five
seconds
he said yeah they saw all the questions
five seconds ago Adam my bad man
uh
boy Rampage yeah we ought to get off
this yeah get back in the conversation
for 30 minutes I'll tell you what I
could wake up you're showing them right
there that's big cat this is coffee big
cat's still a blue coffee this is the
light Rose Positive Vibes I'm a dark
roast guy myself hey big cat send the
dark roast the Electric Avenue send that
dude I don't mess with light roast
however you know the light roast has
more caffeine than dark roast you guys
know that like the stronger the coffee
has to be the light of the roast that's
like all the hipsters they drink the you
know this when it's sour it's like a
real light Bean with tons of caffeine I
hate that [ __ ] it tastes like iced tea I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm getting
when I go to Starbucks really I wish I
was a little bit more snobby with that
oh I I just get the four shots of
espresso over ice I just got a plain
[ __ ] coffee man that's my order
or the Christmas roast is nice right now
yeah me too in and out before I'm yeah
before I'm before I'm out of door it's
gone I'm like I'm not gonna try to sit
there and drink a coffee I'm trying to
yeah I just need the energy his name is
Assassin King and he just got his ass
assassinated and then they're
interviewing him boom he's assassinated
King
right here
his eyes did this show it look at his
eyes yeah he's out
I wish we could hear however hard he's
coping right now
at this point guy you decide to sign up
for rough and round and you're the first
one gets flatlined he's coping for sure
the diamond hands I bet you tonight
speaking of ass play Diamonds hands can
get his ass licked tonight after that
you knock somebody's so clean out you
didn't even scratch them
that poor guy it's like ah dude in this
beard I'd at least like to wake up with
like some damage done to my body so I
could be like something right yeah
concussion probably his DMS aren't going
to be very friendly to him either oh you
think I don't think he's at assassin
King
uh I doubt it you think he's really
assassinated well he's three and two now
his name's assassin King
are you throwing an ad assassin King
there's no way is to handle assassin
King that has to be somebody else
oh chick fight Sarah Sinister
faruga she looks pretty nice 123 000
subscribers what are we saying Adam
she's in Canada like a pretty she's got
a nice smile for somebody who's named
Sinister yeah
123
000 subscribers on YouTube I don't know
what the other girl has that she's
fighting but I'm sure it's similar is it
all YouTube following is it just one of
your biggest song like yeah I think
that's the only thing so she has 900 000
followers OG Vlog Squad oh so she's from
David dobrik's thing wow I don't even
remember oh no no no you know who this
is this is like the Armenian lady that
[ __ ] David dobrik was friends with in
his Vlogs which I'm sure means nothing
to everybody here but yeah
her no now why is she giving her the
thumbs down I do not know but actually I
know this chick too with the [ __ ]
bald head damn you do know her you
remember I met her back in the day you
remember all the [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
I didn't [ __ ]
did Dave dobric he's is he back now
because he was gone for a little bit I
got a pizza spot oh damn that Armenian
base he got something this is the mom
from The David dobrik Vlogs this was
hilarious wow it says
168 and 160. the honey badgers is the
lighter one that ain't right yo if this
lady has a boxing match then anybody
could have a box official you know she
lied about come look at him yeah yeah
they're being friends
right yeah Rampage is right
I'm not gonna call the girl fat enough
but I can definitely tell you the one in
the blue is heavier than the ones
who do you think wins The Armenian she
weighs more than the one yeah yeah the
one in the black don't wait
at this pace these uh ladies are going
out I don't know how far they're gonna
be able to go
oh
[Music]
she's just taking punches but not hard
enough oh they're so tired at that pace
you had some Hunger you think she could
take a lot the girl in the blue yeah it
looks like it would you give her a lot I
don't think so you know how you are with
ass play that's how I am with her you
know
off limits yo there's a guy coming up
who has a handlebar mustache yeah I
surrounded how [ __ ] is that yeah
that's not gonna last past round one yo
that's a beautiful Cowboy would you let
her get it right there with the Pasty
white butt no I'm not gonna lie she
looks like she can do it she's by far
the best one I don't even I only I only
speak English those are real too hey she
can get it beautiful women she can get
it she's a redhead that's what I'm
saying bro she looks trashy as [ __ ] I
love it yeah
right there though are you married guys
girlfriend Cowboys married Adam's about
to get married we're just what are you
pretending if we were like sexually
active but yeah if we're pretending I
would still only sleep with supermodels
hey
fine
now as you want especially since I
plugged her like how many times I mean
you go back I mean at least told her
yeah yeah six seven times on this
podcast I've said how beautiful I at
least dude wouldn't be like my girl
watches two hours into a fight Companion
podcast on the Big Boy network then
whatever you find is your [ __ ]
problem you know like honestly
you're not two hours into this [ __ ]
thing for no reason that's digging yeah
when I drink bro that is called Truth
seeking right there baby and it's just
not like oh
the whole show I I really don't think so
yeah
but if she did but if she did it would
be to catch me slipping yeah
boys
yeah yeah baby if you're still watching
right now baby you bad as it though
you're not a successful podcaster until
you're significant other completely
loses track of of everything that you're
doing on camera
yeah she's like what are you doing yo
look at this person wearing the skin
what the [ __ ] is she wearing that's a
day that's a thing okay that's a
non-binary yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he might be right he might be right that
might be the guy that might be the guy
who had the ass eating on his shirt yeah
they got nothing going on he right
Cowboy is right for once okay
I can't believe he's laser can keep up
this face oh you guys missed the breakup
you guys missed the breaking news
Rampage and he's had a few drinks it was
late in the show he said he's dating a
white girl now which is insane this is
insane right now she should listen to
this because she wanted to don't touch
that [ __ ] she already knows it was
game over she already knows that she
already went for it no no yeah she went
for it Rand but there ain't no girl
gonna eat your
gross big black butthole
you would be surprised
that's what that way
yeah there ain't no ain't happening no I
bet Rampage in the first three tests
she's like how are you good hey I don't
like my ass eating she's like Jesus
Christ she's gonna be a real MMA
fanime fan she's eating rampage's ass
you wanna be surprised she's gonna put
you right on the list
Brock Lesnar Rampage Brandon the whole
time we was filming a couple months ago
we have a confession
where'd the white girl come from yeah
he's been so sweet to me
I met her I met her a long time ago and
she you've known her for a while I'm
alone I met a long time when she and she
hit me up on Instagram and now you're
dating and now we're dating white girl
first white girl no first white girl in
a relationship no does she live here no
I just I guess I just can't assume that
I just assume I like I like all chicks
says I don't think none of the chase is
gonna make it this far in the [ __ ]
since they told me if they do I'm gonna
come back because all you [ __ ]
I'll bets are off hey I have that might
be the best fight of the night though
that didn't and that knockout was great
that girl in the black beat the [ __ ] out
of the yeah that's a little meatball
Canadian chick Sinister yeah Sinister
David Douglas takes another l oh she got
the she got the belt the the yeah
YouTuber belt it's the influencer belt
right now
yeah well that's what they do because
like it was the influencer so I bet she
never had a fight yet she's going over
it's the honey badger oh no she beat the
[ __ ] out yeah hey honey badger take a
shot that's what you get for a line
about her weight though I'm I'm sorry
you can't lie about your weight I was
gonna say that it's like WWE though like
I was gonna say that yeah
yeah okay that's different that's
Entertainment but guess what I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm not a what you call them
misogynist I'm not a misogynist but I
hate when women lie about their [ __ ]
sexual experience their weight
what else
uh what else women like about that way
they lie that they like hey what's up
people are lying about their what's a
body count that would be too much for
you
okay she got five six hundred like me I
know it's too much damn
that your body count way higher than
mine if a girl came to me said I got 500
like if I hit her with the Charlie
Murphy laugh and keep it moving I don't
I don't I'm not allowed on Cowboys I'm
missing out on some good gas for my
friends I don't ask a girl her body
count unless it's gonna get serious
practice makes perfect Cowboy
unless you're getting serious but I'ma
tell you something I don't care you have
to you have to know though
when you get serious you have to know I
don't think it matters it does lie it
does matter I'm telling you why can I
tell you why it's matter they do lie but
you always multiply it but I'm telling
you I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna tell
you this why it matters honestly it
doesn't matter when you're going to get
serious with a girl but it does matter
because of pair bonding and stuff like
that it's true what pair bonding pair
bonding okay if you want to get married
to a chick you don't want a marriage
chick that has a high body count all
right 600 because because she has a
problem
form a close relationship through
courtship and sexual activity with one
another it says animal or person I'm
assuming that animals do it with each
without each other yeah that's not like
I could see myself
interesting if you if you're gonna if
you guys gonna [ __ ] her yeah I don't
care but I don't ask girls if their body
count but if I'm gonna if I'm gonna get
to a point where I'm gonna listen I
think I'm gonna marry this chick the
question I asked you wasn't whether you
asked him I said what is the number that
would deter you away from a girl yeah
for Rampage sounds like yeah you won at
this point is it [ __ ] or like dating
like dating dude your girl like your
girl your girl your girl you're taking
the [ __ ] PF Chang's what's the body
count I just want to know higher or
lower than 200.0 200. there we go just
give me a very vague approximation five
200. 200 is you know if they thought
more than 200 is a lot below 200 there's
nothing like being in a relationship
yeah yeah more than five my God I
wouldn't even talk about five yeah
go hang out with the Mormons I don't
know I don't know what his problem is
but we're alpha males apples we we do
not like a lot of men around us we don't
like a lot of women
said 200. I need a [ __ ] with at least
50. I think I think I think I think as
an alphabet I don't I don't be I don't I
don't I don't concern myself even with
that thought because them [ __ ]
never measured up to me hey Case can we
get a few guys before and then she gonna
still be like yo uh they ain't never
mess it up to anything honestly you got
you got through that because I wasn't
there for it you know and I hit that for
you Jim Rampage said five Cowboy five
that's tough to find these days
look at this [ __ ] guy I know his name
I love his name he has the Guinness
World Record for running a mile
backwards that's your name right that's
got to be a joke right
exactly that's a real a lot of Brendan's
out there
right now though yeah I don't know where
you'd start training for that running
backwards I've never heard of that I
don't think yeah let me tell you when I
say five I know she's probably done like
at least 15. but if she says five it's
like 15 but if she says 10 it's like 40.
what if she tells you five and you have
a bunch of kids together you're together
for five years and then you find out
it's actually 80. but she's your soul
mate yeah now you're in now you're
committed as soon as you ask that
question as soon as that you ask that
question then it puts her in a position
to feel like you you give a [ __ ] about
that so then she might
homeboy in the American shorts has he's
13 and two the other guy's like eight
and six oh yeah
knocked out I don't think so he won't
head butt my dude he's going to lose oh
my God they're fighting so fast the pace
is nuts
especially if having 13 Choice 15 fights
what what fight are we on
he's just taking a rest
I want those shorts there's four fights
there's three fights yeah they look like
jeans yeah
the American flag once
oh they're jeans yeah
yeah yeah they should be losing but
Valley two though you know it's okay I
was just talking about wearing them
around the
boats
no these guys don't
so listen brother let me tell you those
are awful yeah they got two they're
gonna say once even if the girl only
been with two guys they're not gonna say
two they're going to say one either way
good odds Brown Patriots I know you're a
real stickler with this
I'm an alpha man no I get it this is
different you think her body counts one
hell no one thousand but guess what what
I said with our wife no no I get where
you get what I'm saying would be a lot
she can still get it she can still get
it if she [ __ ] a thousand what do you
think your number is probably a thousand
one mine's like 600 maybe I don't know
he was saying for about 250 before I
even started doing porn for real yeah
just from being a piece of [ __ ] your
number at the bar and being on Tinder
I'm like I'm I'm like a 14.
Sam what the [ __ ] you laughing at
home I mean you told she almost had a
force
Force but they don't mean [ __ ] yeah you
didn't do it I didn't do it you just
sucked on their air
my man
that person would have been one yeah
that foursome turns into a threesome
who laughed who was like my girlfriend
no but a foursome is too much like when
you have three girls to yourself it's
like
well it's just kind of it's cool it's
great but it's like functionally there's
not a lot for you to do with more than
two girls
three is a lot when none of them your
girl is fun as [ __ ] no I know I'm
telling you they just how how do you
guys the most experience is the
sloppiest fight of the night
like even the small people yeah they
look the best and then they're fighting
yeah my father went The Armenian lady
was better than that by far and there's
more action-packed that guy's Yosemite
Sam mustache he's terrible they got
their liver King supplements coming in
the mound they still suck
the ref choking them out right there I
just want to know I just want to know if
if his if his I mean his hair looked
like his dive blonde but then his
mother's eyes had to be dive blonde yeah
he didn't bow he'd die double die he
double dot it that guy would probably
instantly get so much more [ __ ] if you
shave that stupid [ __ ] mustache oh
easy yeah it's a conversation about how
much ass he's given up by having that
[ __ ] off you don't think girls like that
some stupid ass hipster chicks maybe we
had a conversation I have no idea what
what girls like I have no idea I could
definitely tell you there's some chicks
that are gonna be like man this guy's
choosing to give up that much ass for
his yeah strength and his mustache
that's so creative he looks like he
works on a boat in the 50s I want to
[ __ ] him yeah
it's a steampunk thing yeah steampunk
yeah it's very uh I lack the language to
describe what the [ __ ] see Adam looks
you you you're a good looking guy you
said you got you had sex claws but thank
you a thousands I can say that because
I'm 100 hey I'm so straight
no no I'm so straight I'm a lesbian I
can say it okay so come on so you can
you can say that you have sex with over
a thousand chicks close to that maybe so
you can give your opinion on that what
about the guy having a mustache and I'm
just saying yeah to me it's a weird look
like if yeah it's very strange if I was
this man that's a weird look no but as
an MMA fighter it's really good branding
because you're probably not going to
forget that you just [ __ ] saw this
guy right you know but but think about
it guys that girl must act like that
they probably already in a committed
relationship that's what I think yeah
yeah that's a that's a guy who's married
who grows on a mustache like that yeah
that's what I think his whole vibe the
mustache the shorts he's like yeah
you're not gonna if you get your ass
whooped or whoop that guy you gonna be
like you know that [ __ ] blonde
mustache guy yeah whoop my [ __ ] I
won't do that I mean it's like [ __ ]
mustache I just needs to land one I mean
the worst thing that could happen in
your MMA career besides like losing
fights is just that you're like an
anonymous guy that doesn't speak English
and nobody ever really becomes fans of
you and then it's like it's very like
uphill battle for you to [ __ ] do well
versus this guy if he [ __ ] was a good
fighter they're just going to be all
over them because he is memorable I
guess these two are the toughest of the
night meaning and not in a good way
I still say the guy with the America
with the mustache is going to lose I
mean you got you got 15 to make my whole
career off that I think on three rounds
yeah unless somebody gets knocked out
we're all losing I'm the mustache guy
I literally make my whole career off
that like just just this gimmick of like
oh I would have expected this voice to
come out of this guy that's literally
like that whole [ __ ]
that's literally my whole stick I mean
even if you break it down I don't even
know if my voice is that great dude your
voice I could definitely tell you you're
gonna see my face and then the voice
will come out you're like whoa I never
respect you never heard them
yeah like chin told me I am that
mustache
quarter quarter truck no I wish that we
could play your stuff because you're so
[ __ ] amazing everyone oh it's nice
well yeah I'm not fishing I'm just
saying that I am that guy man I'm
definitely working again like I grew up
on I grew up on WWE we worked the
[ __ ] gimmick you know what I'm
saying we it's just like somebody hey
fight somebody you know yeah I would
never ask him but that guy's the same
tattoos as Frankie Edgar he won I was I
was wrong so I was wrong and they got a
belt too
so I'll
trap zilla's next and he's fun who his
name's trapzilla he's a former male or
he might be a current ale stripper yeah
this boy is trapped how you know how you
know who's next because I had to break
down the fights to do a trailer for this
and they had the trapzilla on there I
watched him fight his his pacing yeah
uh I mean yeah they hired me to do it so
I'm gonna tell you something I'm drunk
now so I can talk freely yeah I'm gonna
tell you something I'm I'm more proud of
you than anybody else that ever came
from The Ultimate Fighter oh thanks
brother because you you've done a lot of
[ __ ] and you've done something that I'm
actually afraid to do you don't stand up
your face stand up I'm a fan I'm a fan I
don't watch it a whole lot because I'm
weird like that but um I do my my com my
comedy with the MMA fans oh yeah you're
hilarious that's why I love the honest
yeah I like making people laugh I don't
know I'm not a stand-up comedian because
I couldn't I could never do what
comedians do it takes a lot of balls to
stand in front of the crowd to solely
try to make them laugh so what I do is
um I do my my comedy
um only strictly with the MMA fans at
certain times I I have my stick the
stuff that I say I've been saying it for
years my own like [ __ ] but I never do
like stand up yeah you're funny just in
conversation you're funny on here that's
why I love you that's why I like that's
why that's why I always sell here yeah I
always like to be a stand-up I can what
got um all those people always want you
to slap them where'd that [ __ ] come from
oh okay this is what it came from
the guy just passed away you you guys
know uh Antonio Enoki right you should
know him yeah yeah you know him you
Asian because you know him that's racist
that I said that well Japanese but yeah
he's like
you're Korean so this Japanese guy he
was a pro wrestler in Japan he was so
famous that he fought Muhammad Ali in
the first ever MMA fight ever before the
Brazilians invented it you remember that
fight did you ever see it so that guy
what's his name Antonio he's right there
next time right next year okay so so one
time I was in Japan
and it was that the one in my fights and
I'm just watching Japanese TV and this
guy was he was on TV so I watched it I
can't understand [ __ ] but he slapped
this woman so hard that she flew off
camera and she came back what happened
was he he tried to stop and she moved
and she came back and she slapped him
and he looked at he had a crazy look on
his face he was like Wham he slept off
camera I was like what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] on TV slapping [ __ ] and
so I figured out that it was an honor to
be slapped by him so what I did was I
started going after that I started going
around Japan slapping Japanese people
and that's where I was born and Japanese
people they they just assignment this is
a bid on itself
it's real they like the sign of respect
respect look at traps I'm telling
trapped up he's built like a stingray
so so what what is it like a you you
wouldn't pursue comedy because it's like
a is it like a stage fright thing or
like yeah yeah I think I think I'd be I
think I'll be scared to get up on stage
I I have a lot of respect for comedians
because think about this you got to get
up on stage
and be funny what have you bombed like
yeah like something you're gonna bomb
you're gonna bomb you can eat [ __ ] and
and oh yeah everyone does I've seen some
of the best in the world I saw Chris
Rock bomb at the The Comedy Store yeah
we're doing it 30 years just part of the
game yeah and I think he's working on
stuff and but I can't deal with that so
what I do is I don't know if you guys
know there's a lot of [ __ ] that I've
just been saying I just I I think it's
funny to me so so my problem is I grew
up in a real negative environment I was
like the yeah I'm the white sheep of my
family
okay thank you and and so I had for me
growing up I always that's why I could
look I could look really mean because I
always like was really in a bad bad uh
mood I was always mean I was always
right my family and stuff like they they
I'm a middle child and they and I'm
nothing like my siblings so they just
[ __ ] exercise are you cool with them
now
yeah I love making people laugh I have
older cousins that like smoke weed and
they used to come and make me read The
Laffy taffies to make them laugh that's
it and so I just grew up like I like
making people laugh when I want to laugh
I just look at this guy's back and I
think about how hairy it is that
[ __ ] need to do something bro it
looks like he's good and it's split like
right in the middle he don't grow it
like right there yeah that's even worse
it's like he has wings made of hair
he is not on Prime you're all like mad
MMA fighters have wings tattooed on
their back yeah Ben hands that's a weird
thing that like MMA fighters and
strippers haven't come out just had to
do a big set of wings on my back this
guy did that but with hair oh my boy
he's a Savage though because this trap
all fight before on a rough and round
and he was bringing he looks a little
timid this time he's a male stripper is
he really yeah
that's your boyfriend he got the thick
on the back he got that's that's your
boy you know what that means right here
you know what that means I know some
gangster ass male strippers though I'm
not gonna lie oh yeah how do you know
how you know male strippers Adam because
I interview a lot of people some
percentage of him while Rico's strong
he's a porn star now but he told me he
used to strip
[Laughter]
that's it
[Laughter]
shut up man
as long as she can eat your ass make
sure they move you up in the schedule
bro
I'll be the first let a woman have for
500 000 person body count but damn sure
I ain't gonna let no man take my woman
yeah I didn't let her eat Rampage his
ass
that dude really has the thick boy on
his shorts can you imagine
your ass no
I just feel like it's probably got some
murkiness I feel like it has dark energy
okay yeah that's some there's some
Memphis there's some Memphis Memphis
hey real quick do you think because that
guy put my thick boy thing on shorts I
should pay him even though [ __ ] yeah you
should pay he's probably send some money
he put thick boy in his truck yeah I
didn't ask him to trapzilla is that your
boy though you know him no I mean I
covered him I hyped it up but yeah
when Mike if he wins if he wins give him
give him something tell him he's got a
cross on there too so it's like post
them I think I think you get I think
you're giving enough but I just shout
him out right now hey shout out to
Travis no I think he's giving five grand
I'm gonna tell you this big boy
damn John Dutton big boys good then as
far as big guys you know yeah exactly
because because man we man we we we
we're supposed to be busy
you're not supposed to be big I'm big
though can you speak 300 pounds shut the
[ __ ] up
he always cracks me it was 285 but it
used to be 300 pounds 285 chin bring up
the picture yeah
I don't believe it
Debbie Cowboy chin has a picture he's at
the prom and he's about 300 pounds Sadie
Hawkins the girl sitting on his lap he
looks like a one of those people that
have been ventriloquists
I don't believe he used to be 285. I was
25. how much you weigh right now uh 197.
shut the [ __ ] up
that's fine I don't believe that I
didn't either until I saw this picture
the picture's kind of crazy because
how'd you do it you ate a bunch of liver
yeah by the way yeah
I don't hate liver King
it's gonna take a long time
oh Jenkins sing dang all right we got to
get him to take you a little oh yeah
Teddy I I did a track with jelly really
yeah me jelly and I yeah no I gotta send
him some money yeah you gotta send him
some money bro we admit you didn't tell
me oh never mind never mind
I'm a singer dude you're making you look
bad did you but that's not how
sponsorships work you don't just like
wear a Nike logo
yeah right the second time we're hanging
out you didn't put the big one it's
airbrushed so I'm sure you put some
effort into it don't feel bad but you
didn't ask them it's gonna take forever
I'm gonna send them something for sure I
need to get a good picture
how you hear it dude I'm a fan dude I
didn't promote nothing though no no but
I followed you for forever so oh that's
cool you're my friend now that you all
right thank you but I didn't ever
promoted anything uh Woodley wraps yeah
oh that's good yeah who's okay there's a
good question who's the best like UFC
fighter ready no no he's not you know
what and I love Woodley there's chin fat
with the girl that he has his hand it
looks like I'm an actual ventriloquist
that's right hey but you look good at
that weight though you look good you
know that's a big guy yeah you look way
better now yeah you look way better now
but you didn't look I was expecting
I was expecting you to look like homeboy
over here
26 weeks yeah that's a long time ago I
looked back I made it I was like I hope
you ain't [ __ ] point in mine what's
your name again they cross Mike the two
bigger guys looked at when you said that
I'm
oh hell yeah dude can I tell you
something though the girls that like big
guys yeah
are good they're good women all of them
the girls are like big guys are good
women though all of them dude I think
about that whenever I look at the photos
of me when I was way fatter and then I'm
just like damn my girl's like really
nice for not telling me to lose weight
but she was good she was like how big
were you a good woman though I was like
I lost like 30 pounds in the last four
months and I was just looking at my
before photos and I was just like holy
[ __ ] and how tall are you you were
[ __ ] you're tall dude yeah I'm uh six
three you're six three so you wasn't
that 15 right now that's what I'm saying
that's what that's what made me stop is
just like
for porn sake I need to get in shape
because what you do you just ate change
your diet and meal prep and [ __ ] yeah
that didn't end well is he in prison for
rape oh yeah for like nine years
he has a he looked bad he could have got
all the [ __ ] in the world and he just
wanted to go take something he's screwed
that's [ __ ] up
uh so many people got me too dude the
[ __ ] rainbow room so the last day yes
they were saying that like girls would
go to take photos with them at porn
conventions and he'd [ __ ] Jam his
fingers up the [ __ ] and [ __ ] all kinds
of weird [ __ ] about him with girls
yeah I can't stand dudes like that he's
screwed I can't stand dude I mean it's
pretty hair right now yeah yeah yo got a
lot I know he got like a long story yeah
what is it when is this not good enough
to have a decision where you're just
like no I want what I can't have like
and I'm gonna grab it like I'm gonna get
it
and now he's just this old creepy weirdo
and he's just still treating chicks like
he's the man you know I kind of assume
it's like that yeah because other people
started true but then also for all those
male porn stars like
you know the rides over at some point my
man you can't be doing this oh yeah you
can when you got the hammer like drawn
you can go forever no there's the
[ __ ] don't really want to [ __ ] was it
run was he oh yeah
oh he had a meat sticker yeah yeah I've
seen it yeah
what do you mean like that [ __ ] doggy
style with your hands except on their
ass
that's tight I didn't even [ __ ] around I
was doing that before I knew about Ron
Jeremy it's actually a really dumb
technique because you're basically
covering the part where the camera wants
to see your dick going in and out but
I've heard that he invented that so well
extra arms in the right place because
I've literally I know they've never done
the camera there ain't no cameras yeah I
will never let Cameron see me doing yeah
so Ron Jeremy I've never seen a Ron
Jeremy videos but I'd be doing that and
so it's like I never seen one you know
it's like when people tell me that they
don't like the Beatles And I'm like no I
swear to God the band you listen to are
influenced by The Beatles you can't tell
me you don't like the Beatles the same
thing your girl's ass when you hitting
it from doggy style do you smack the
best
okay I got another question I got
another question raise your hands you
ever motivated a girl butt cheeks
well I ate the butt too while I was no
no no it's not eating it but it's like
making them laugh like it's not a sexual
thing remember being funny yeah most
girls never had that butt cheeks
motivated what that's a shame that's a
shame do you well you have the speaking
of motorboating uh booties you got the
occasion Punisher versus the mech that
now they're 215 so this would be a
heavyweight and I think he's a partial
employee
to that yeah they're girls in their 215
holy [ __ ] I didn't even know they made
girls that big would you [ __ ] a girl
that's 215. I'm gonna try not to no but
but once you come on your podcast and
she's a porno star listen I could get
hard for any girl I think but I'm not
really sure how can you get so hard for
any girl though because I'm a
professional man I do my thing
fat chicks for free back in the day with
my homies for no reason which I don't
really know why in retrospect but
whether you can get it
for the other girl yeah uh one time back
in the day day one of my homies got a
chick to come over the crib from
Craigslist and she was like 400 pounds
when we all gang banged her I was like
19. what the [ __ ] was wrong with you bro
no it was like the grossest [ __ ] I ever
did did you eat her ass hell
you're so gross nothing isn't that crazy
I assuming you a condo with all these
[ __ ]
I'm tested I can test it every two weeks
Yeah Tuesday I wore a condom God damn
that's tender bro that's standard it's
like fighting with gloves on actually
it's not even like that we fight with
gloves on so I know I know like big big
gloves so you know what all these all
these chicks on your only fans you
interview you don't wear condom whenever
you test them did they get tested and we
get tested we're all in the system porn
stars there's a system yeah we all go to
the same Club are you on PornHub yeah
you straight up porn star only
plugtalk.com you can watch us interview
a chick and then [ __ ] her after a new
one every week no only plugtalk.com or
check out like plug talk on Instagram
um massive when I introduced him he's
like the the P Diddy of I'm gonna tell
you something I've seen it I scroll Tick
Tock and I've seen his face but I can't
I'm telling you I'm not into point so I
kept going but I've seen other things as
well you know my main thing is I
interview rappers and [ __ ] yeah she's a
rap head so he has no jumper it's
massive that's funny because I said
afterwards like yo you should do my
podcast and he was gonna be like yeah
I'm not [ __ ] your ticket I do your
pocket where's your Park asset uh
yeah you're in La yeah per Bank yeah
dude no drama is like the biggest I mean
it's a massive dude
to promote some of the movies man Cowboy
you don't need to just come talk about
whatever he's great yeah
okay he's one of the best in the game
but Kanye West was going to do his
podcast you're not gonna ask me to [ __ ]
your chick though are you no that's a
different podcast well I'm not doing it
if I wanted to get a big black out of
[ __ ] my chick I know all these pornstar
dudes I'm sure would be happy to oblige
yeah but you're on you're next on the
list after all them but currently we're
not going through the role okay okay hey
put me on the list before then right
curly curly my wife is not getting
filled out by another man so uh
it's exhausting he seems to be as happy
as a pig and [ __ ] to be honest he can't
stick his whole dick he can't stick his
whole dick in a girl he didn't act like
it's a curse but honestly
when I've seen videos the girls hook it
up with them bro like they're deep
throating like the first like four
inches or whatever like he ain't getting
head like the way I'm getting hit right
because his [ __ ] is just too much it's
also it's like it's also super thick
dude it's [ __ ] insane
he's rich and everything because of it
because of porn but it's it's kind of a
curse yeah he's a curse trust me he's a
curse well I mean for men like dude it's
probably a curse for him but for men
everywhere he probably keeps up the
facade that's amazing
yeah we all want that for some other
[ __ ] reason because I've known dudes
throughout the years who had way smaller
dicks than him that told me that
straight up they had girlfriends where
it didn't work out because they couldn't
[ __ ] him because their dick was too big
and this guy's like literally like two
times bigger than those dudes I'm sure
yeah yeah I'm telling you the girls like
it's very sad like me like like an Asian
chicks I couldn't have a 15 inch dick
[ __ ] the chicks
I don't want I don't want to say this
but since I'm drunk off this [ __ ]
tiger thick I'm gonna say go ahead I
know girls say [ __ ] when they're happy
with you but every girl I ever dated all
say the same thing that I'm the just the
right side
I get all three holes fresh
and and they said I'm I'm I have a cute
one because evidently some of my ugly
it's cute
to describe my wieners no no is it
symmetrical
listen I got a mushroom that they like
they like the mushrooms okay so one up
it's not no hey every hey I have to I
have to accept it as truth because all
girls they don't know each other I make
sure that and it's all unanimous that
they like the way it looks they like the
way it looks and they like the size
so if I had a 15er if you had a Yelp
review it would be five stars yeah well
and I could I could definitely tell you
about I could definitely tell you about
your stature alone even if you had a
little wiener for your stature it would
still be bigger than the little winner
the big wiener I'd have on my side
and she said that that she [ __ ] Shaq
and Shaq had a little dick I'm like okay
I've heard that I'm on Shack if Shaq has
a [ __ ] normal porn [ __ ] it might look
small because he's so big right yes
dude Shaq's micropenis would still be
bigger than my five seven little ass
could have a Monster yeah but you're
shocked you're expecting you know don't
think about it think about it big diesel
think about if you're a girl and Shaq it
is Big it's got a piece you see a big
body with Shaq's normal-sized penis
right you're gonna think it's small
that's why I went that's why I don't
send dick pics because my hands are big
but you know who are the the that's why
the unheard swamps
Rampage you know who the victims are in
our society the black men who have small
dicks and have to live with the
stereotype that black men have big dicks
bro we love that stereotype because I'm
average dude
are like yeah out here just attacking in
silence yeah it's disaster but that's
what I'm saying dude I set the bar so
low so when I get in the bed I'm just
killing but white guys we don't have
that stigma for white guys white guy
you're supposed to have bad dick right
yeah no I said I got a great dig it's
just not
my manager saw who I was coming on this
podcast with it was like ah man just
make sure you don't say [ __ ]
something that's good don't talk about
trans people don't tell them how big
your penis is you're supposed to be a
family friendly [ __ ] just a feminine
I said when the [ __ ] did I sign up for
that I would say no no I'd say no never
mind you know what it is the problem is
YouTube Just they flag everything you
can't say certain things oh we're done
yeah oh no we're certain in Orange we're
going to request it yeah right it just
affects them
on YouTube when the video gets like the
ads taken off it turns orange and then
you have to try to request them to
monetize
brother every live stream I do I haven't
drank since Thailand
after I've been home for like four days
but if you like don't do it live and you
just upload it then it's much more
likely to be monetized and much less
likely to become demonetized later
YouTube it's really annoying because
YouTube wants you to stream but then
they make it like way harder to make
money while streaming and then what they
do is suppress the view so because we're
so like graphic on this to make sure it
doesn't get can you can you create the
numbers you can't like you can't like
Bleed It Out yeah I mean we'd have to
bleep you out there you could film it
beforehand and then put it I mean dude I
imagine somebody having to sit here and
listen to this and bleep out the last
four hours of conversation and then you
could also still tell we're talking
about [ __ ] today
I don't
it'd take a week to go through this
conversation and bleep out [ __ ] that it
would still be very clear this is the
only place where it lives on YouTube if
Brandon told me that I couldn't talk
about you know gay [ __ ] I would just
like jump out the window yeah I'm gonna
land on a bush downstairs no I don't
censor anything yeah
why is YouTube so like hard hard ass
because they want to make the
advertisers happy so they're just like
super overzealous about trying to keep
the content clean and just make you jump
through all these ridiculous
people it's an algorithm yeah advertise
is the one to get the money you know but
that's also woke laugh too so you know
there's a narrative they want to have a
streaming Network that you can do
whatever you want Rumble Rumble yeah I
heard about that
but uh who uh recently who went their
homeboys
a bunch of people like if you want to
watch all the people who've been
basically banned up YouTube It's kind of
getting to the point where there's like
like I go on there a decent amount like
when I wanted to find Alex Jones talking
to Kanye I gotta go on there I think
that but they have around like maybe 80
to 100 million subscribers and YouTube
has like you know yeah I heard about
this when Andrew Tate went there I'm
gonna say this um he really rich yeah
yeah he looks Rich he sells courses I'm
not sure what he was doing before that
you know he's the world champion
kickboxer
you mean the world's worst kickboxer on
the planet did you fight him cowboy no
but Joe Shilling tried to fight him many
times and he would never fight Joe well
you thought he was he's trash because
everybody actually is super legit I've
never seen him
messing around and and have you seen his
fights on YouTube
I like I like I like Andrew Tate let me
see let me say this I like him the stuff
some of the stuff is I don't agree with
100 of stuff he says but I like I like
you put a fight up but but his fight for
you guys to watch him yeah which one I'm
a fighter I can say like
Joe's about it yeah
that's a real world champ yeah yeah so I
don't know what but you know kickboxing
it's kind of like boxes
bka though
he look like PKA but this might be a
multi fight but look like I thought he
was a PKA nah man look that's a World
Champ yes
sloppy I've never seen him fight that's
a World Champ no you sure as hell ain't
being jokes come on that's a World Champ
look at how back he is on his back feet
he's interesting because he didn't come
from money right his dad his dad's like
a chess player I don't know how he got
money all of a sudden I didn't know if
it was a real thing man it was in like a
[ __ ] massive house full of cam girls
at one point and that's what he caught
that trafficking charge over that I
don't think actually became it was that
real travel yeah it was just kind of
squatting on him there yeah see trash
can
and they see a world champion at this
point in his life but I have no idea I
don't know anything about it
or a kickboxing many years this is a
year ago 2.4 years a year ago so yes oh
wow
this is so interesting to me to watch uh
like a fighter watch a fighter and then
talk about like all right well let's
let's just talk about Cowboys he doesn't
look great here no matter I started
kickboxing for anything but look at the
guy he's fighting does that look like an
athlete to you yeah yeah it's like one
of the guys been watching them yeah he's
a high level guy so that he's fighting
that guy and then now granted fighting a
shitty fighter is going to be harder
because they they're sloppy but there's
he doesn't have any
yeah
yeah he after watching this I haven't
seen Jake Paul be a handful look at him
look at hands down it seems like Jake
Paul was [ __ ] murder this guy and for
the listeners it's uh Andrew Tate versus
Cosmic Ling you are link your viewer but
wow I've never seen if I just you just
hear he's a world champion I think hey
can you Google that uh Cosmic whoever is
to see what his record is yep I think
Andrew Jake Paul's probably like the
biggest fight that Jake Paul could get
for money-wise yeah he's so viral right
now I think everybody would actually
tune in so this dude's fighting he's
still viral even being kicked off all
the platforms huh oh yeah but he's back
on Twitter now that was that only that
was his only fight that's all I'm seeing
here on topology just say what year that
was Jim yeah that's 20 years ago 2020.
tough that was his only fight okay
what's Andrew Tate's record
let's see I know he had a I thought he
had a bunch of fights we got a main
event Pac-Man
what'd you say Jen what's good
Wikipedia one was right down oh oh it
says total fights but who knows what
this is 176 out of his 85 professional
kickboxing and nine losses yeah
23 by knockout but I don't know how
legit this is yeah I wanna I wanna see
the people he's fighting yeah
and he fought MMA interesting
yeah I don't know maybe that was maybe
he came out of retirement for that fight
against that guy who's well that's him
Owen one I've been worn at all
professionally this is the main event
yeah yeah that's the main event that's
the last one boys all right I want to
see this
I just totally like it just uh makes
this like such an art form to me that
I've never realized before because you
know you just could watch a I guess a
fighter watching a fighter and judge
based off of how they move and how
they're you know it's such a weird thing
I could show you in the first
he's just been chilling and that was
like uh well I was talking to Joe like
who is this dude and he was like oh man
[ __ ] that dude I've been trying to fight
him for years he's just got a bunch of
hype doesn't ever fight anybody and I
was like really and then I started
seeing videos of it and then I seen
videos someone posted over him
kickboxing was like this dude yeah he's
a world champion
so but I never I never got dove into him
or seen anything about I just I just was
curious how he went from whatever to
being loaded because I want that fast
track yeah
with business I know Raiders fighting
but I don't know I don't agree with
everything he says but some of the [ __ ]
he he's talking about when I first
started learning who he is I agree with
some of the viral videos yeah some of
the [ __ ] he said no but a lot of us is
Clips
I interviewed this dude fairly recently
he just got uh this dude that I know
just got caught I don't know robbing a
jewelry store for 87 000 yeah from Long
Beach uh and he talks about it how are
you gonna talk about the robbing the
jury story I don't think he talks about
it previously and then he robbed them oh
he got locked up so he already I never
heard of that guy yeah he's not that big
he's a he was a rapper she's probably
gonna be rapping in jail too yeah oh he
just got locked up yeah okay they can't
find Pac-Man
they looked in the bathroom and stuff is
that him there is that that's uh lights
out Lang
Pac-Man doesn't want to fight oh my gosh
boy that'd be it that'd be tough yeah
they can't end on that last fight no
that's him right oh there he is they
found him maybe he's just doing his
thing I wanted to be real sure before I
was like no that's
cut his right finger on a glass blunt
tip last night are you serious like a
glass blunt what the [ __ ]
man
how do you break the glass blunt and
like still be holding on to it to the
extent where it cuts your finger open
yeah this is what I wonder what he's
getting paid because if you remember
Pac-Man Jones was the real deal man he
was so damn good at football
hey if any of y'all know me out there
thick tiger
thick damn
that's how drunk I am it's all good guys
that's easy to mix up it should be
called thick tiger [ __ ] [ __ ] Mr Suave
you ever look at a tiger and just think
damn damn
horses like [ __ ] even though you get
even though you get buzzed you don't
want to stop that's how smooth it is
like I should have stopped like two
hours ago
your wiener and they're still going when
I talked about it I enjoy it no no I'm
glad
what else are you gonna tell us you're
going to give me a bottle of this right
yeah
and I can buy this at any liquor store
after that you can get at thick boy.com
thick boy.com I gotta go to thickboy.com
not you I'll send it to you yes sir you
can take them all night in Austin
uh thick boy a bottle yeah I should
probably send him a bottle yeah you guys
seen him that's the handwritten thank
you that's the move yeah even though he
got knocked out thank you he got he got
knocked out he didn't get yummy yeah no
no no he lost that fight oh yeah he lost
the fight he didn't get back up which is
weird he looks so good he's a big boy
you're gonna get a bottle a handwritten
thank you note and then a uh Christmas
five percent off for your family uh for
the murder gift code yeah very realistic
hand-drawn illustration of rampage's
[ __ ] no it's his [ __ ] the
um
I drink too much of it I'm like wasting
all his bottles it's so good it's like
it's based off of that Japanese style
whiskey right what the [ __ ] he got me
with the Japanese whiskey you got me
with the Japanese version it would get
you [ __ ] even though you're dating a
white girl now I knew you'd come back
yeah come back around and come back to
the Asians yep come back today
Stormtrooper you know the first girl
ever kiss was Asian right that makes
sense that's why you like him
Puerto Rican I'm wearing a 311 shirt I
had a Puerto Rican freaking they
freaking they freaky as [ __ ] first girl
I kissed a black girl and my friend
pulled my pants down oh not racist not
racist at all hey I knew he wasn't
raised the first time I met him that's
why we've been friends yeah I passed the
test he passed the test toughest guy in
New England Earth slash Earth in New
England not he's not a toughest guy on
earth I say it's a toss-up between me
and cowboy
when I became a big fan of cowboy
can I tell you what fight please the
fight where he did that combo on a guy
when he [ __ ] punched him oh story
and he did a combo he ended with the
kick in the face yeah the Mortal Kombat
was like Mortal Kombat I was like die
hard fan of cowboy since then yeah
Cowboy I think you threw the one two and
then he went to slide out I've always
I've always liked Cowboy I was like his
his game like I think MMA fighters a lot
of a lot of MMA fighters that have too
much of an ego they don't have like a
gimmick I like the fact that he doesn't
[ __ ] celebrate it pretty much it just
kind of like walks away yeah that's like
the best [ __ ] I always like Fedor for
that yeah Fedor hey jump on the [ __ ]
ring it's like I get it you're high but
yeah chill out yeah that's bars right
there though they have too much of ego
not enough a lot a lot of Fighters have
but but what you guys got to understand
this that is a release of today I'm sure
it's the best feeling it's the best
that's why I think about how much
self-control it takes yeah to not run
around and [ __ ] screaming gotta tell
you why one reason why I never tried
drugs my biggest high is when I knock
somebody out yeah or when I finish
somebody when the referee I don't like
but you ever knock somebody out on drugs
but I don't like I haven't I like I like
I like when referee pulled me off
someone yeah but it's my biggest high
when I knock somebody out hey do we
think Pac-Man's gonna lose this right
now
I think the white guy I think the white
guy got this one
ain't no guy fighting the 0-1 guy this
is a fight no I think it's because he's
like ain't knowing this stuff like he's
not like legit who's famous the other
guy Batman is 0-1 I know but yeah like
Adam Sanders he's famous that's right
he's famous the other guy's not so who's
famous
he played for the Cowboys the black guy
yeah he was he was he played for the
Cowboys like as a as a yeah but they put
him up against a big [ __ ] yeah
they didn't give him some pushovers that
guy finna lose I'm sorry yes yeah
of this lights out laying he just
doesn't stop he don't give a [ __ ]
these guys look like they care about
fighting right uh Cowboy uh white guy
cares more than Pac-Man they they
definitely have been trained you say yes
you know what it is Adam sometimes
people underestimate their opponents
that that happens a lot in this sport
yeah in the full contact support I could
imagine
so who these guys are who they're there
for they're there for that lights out
Lang I guess that's a scene scene that's
this thing this storm trooper [ __ ] I
guess for the main event they should
have made it two minutes at least I
agree
two minutes
I got too much I'm busy yeah what are
you doing on tours how many podcasts you
miss standing up in how many podcasts
and uh I do find the kid twice a week
the goal now with crystalia once a week
then I do the shop show and I do food
truck and then Fight Night flashback so
five yeah yeah plus touring I've seen
your food truck one is yeah you're good
yeah I'm supposed to do a food truck
with you for the The Fight League with
our boy Harrison and Frank Mayer hey
they're growing their Fight League is
growing yeah you know what you know what
he's about right yeah yeah you wanna you
wanna get your own team one day that'd
be fun that'd be dope yeah because
you're involved with it right yeah yeah
I would love for you have your own team
in my team yeah
get his own team
I want did I say it wrong [ __ ] all right
it's all good I'm drunk Schwab yeah
should I tell you something
he has a very unusual name yeah it is
[Music]
look at all the Storm Troopers you think
you you think that you're fighting
though no
when you first got started was that like
something you did your whole life up no
[ __ ] no I never I didn't grow up
fighting at all I grew up playing
football and being a goofball
said ball twice so how did you end up
even
unfortunately
falling into fighting
I'm not like Cowboys you know
is falling into fighting is just not
something I could swab
well there's Charles dude the guy who
[ __ ] up is Charles schwart yeah that
Charles Charles Schwab was like the
financial can I tell you something
brother what man you have a hard name
you think [ __ ] yeah he was just Clinton
though that's tough come on it's a it's
a lot more Quentin than Brendan's
Schwabs how do you say is I think
Brendan is a more common name than
Quentin yeah you think so yeah and then
you and then really people call you
Rampage which is really unique yeah yeah
are you a poker player named Rampage
yeah yeah I heard about him really yeah
I heard about him how did poker player
get the nickname Rampage can I tell you
something can I tell you something I
don't know my friend is like you fight I
just signed up with this one guy we just
formed a production company he wants me
to do a podcast I'm like
I don't want to do a podcast but
you know everybody got podcasts I don't
know if I do being good at the podcast
he wants to hear about it you would not
be back but you need like a co-host
who's gonna like control you control
yeah yeah yeah
right like uh like Teddy swims
I like poker I suck at poker but he
wants me to do a poker podcast
well we just play poker and talk [ __ ] oh
well that is a cool idea the [ __ ]
camera in the table yeah I know that's
what I'm thinking it's a lot right it is
it costs like 20 grand or 50 grand for
the table or something and then you get
gas the gas would not play poker right
right so it's too much right that's just
one fight that's just one fight with
Jake Paul away from getting all that
money you need no right right that's
what I'm saying because I like poke
because he know I like poker right the
poker audience though it's like there's
not that many people who really get it
but and also you'd have to show your
cards right they're doing like World
Series yeah yeah that's what I was
thinking that's what I was thinking I
don't know or just do a podcast not play
poker you know because I've thought
about that maybe you could sit around
and play the cards and not show it yeah
but then that's super boring yeah it is
then like he said he can't he's I told
this is all the concerns that I had when
he told me I said he said we can show
the cards he can show them and he just
balls deep in poker but he wants you to
play Pokemon
I like I'm not good but I like poker
I've been learning it but you like it my
friend Jason out there he's like my
brother now oh you came with somebody
yeah my friend Jason I don't know if I
met him no you met him last time I came
here okay but maybe let's briefly he's
like my he's like my brother he's like a
younger brother to me and he's been
teaching me about poker and I really
love it I love my poker extra I can get
you deep in the game yeah poker too deep
no I don't I don't trust you because
you're gonna have me playing poker and
[ __ ] porno [ __ ]
no that's a separate part of my life
I like making money
you know you know Tito Ortiz you don't
know do you know him yeah when Tito
Ortiz he's a man oh yeah when he married
when he married a porno song I had a
couple of porno I feel like he's kind of
lost his mind I'm gonna be realized he
ran for what was he a uh his apology
something like that so that that's why I
think he lost him yeah it's basically
like awesome stuff I learned about him
throughout him I don't judge my friend
if my if my if my brother Cowboy ran for
a like mayor of [ __ ]
Albuquerque I wouldn't give I would
support him he's John that's in his
future it's season five yeah I don't
judge myself
I didn't care one way or another and I
watched that show and I hit him he's a
character yeah I'm feeling better hands
with hand than I do but okay so who do
we ever won this job they gave it to
lights out lane
for cowboy to be the person he is and be
a cowboy and stuff like that you're not
honestly for black you're not expecting
for him to like [ __ ] but he's cool as
[ __ ] you know I'm saying how could you
not like cowboy right he like [ __ ] hey
if you if you if
you like [ __ ] you
last time I saw Tito Ortiz I was in
Portland on tour and there's the that's
the clip right there is that there's the
proud boys
there's proud boys and they tell me
don't leave the hotel room it's crazy
you shouldn't have came this weekend
like whatever I'm walking on the street
to get coffee I run to Tito and I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here Tito's
like just
came to see the city I'm like no doubt
coming to show nice like yeah yeah what
time is I'm like somebody's like yeah
I'll be there manly leave two tickets
I'm like oh cool but what are you doing
here he's like just hanging out he's
there for the for the round yeah you
know he's got friends with Donald Trump
you know that right well yeah yeah I
know you learned that like did you did
you remember he was on that reality show
with them that's right yeah uh what
you're fired Apprentice the prince
you're fired can I say this I don't give
a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about me but I'm
a fan of Donald Trump
out still yeah yeah guess what I don't
give a [ __ ] about Mean Tweets Mean
Tweets I don't give a [ __ ] about Mean
Tweets I mean you might get a I mean
that's the thing though it's if you
would have said I'm a fan of you know
means Biden you would have got shipped
that if you say a fan of trump you're
gonna sit for for whatever you say Yeah
in this world in America you're gonna
get [ __ ] for whatever you say so my
choice is to be real I'm a fan of Donald
Trump
because honestly when Donald Trump was
President we had it [ __ ] was better [ __ ]
was better I'm sorry but what people
don't know is a lot of us are sheep
that's what we don't know that's what
that's what we don't know if you if you
are truly a sheep
you don't know that you're a sheep
that's real I don't listen they don't
mean I love you less I love everybody
but Rampage do you think you're a fan of
trump just because your options no they
buy it in trouble or just Trump over
even to Santa no who is DeSantis I don't
know who he's the you'd be like the
competition for Trump for the Republican
Party well I'm gonna be honest I got to
listen to us and DeSantis yeah I don't
know him yeah so I have to be like Trump
you'd probably like him he's like Trump
but more dialed down okay so uh what
they call him day sanctimonious yeah
that's what Trump now so think about it
so those two go to war is bad news for
the Republican party because it's gonna
be like a [ __ ] Civil War I think
they're saying we can get we can get
political events at some point but I'm a
person I'm a person of common sense
because I'm I'm gonna be straight up I'm
not 100 educated I I I turned against
education when I was in [ __ ]
Elementary School oh wow and they were
telling me that Christopher Columbus
discovered America oh you know it in
fifth grade foreign
party his wife just beat cancer that's a
good point so she having an IB cancer
party that'd be fun yeah it's gonna be
fine I'm gonna be drunk
[Applause]
that was a seven he's at a nine right
now with the monster oh God damn
some Choice Awards was sponsored by
Hurley whatever Hurley used to take care
of me back in the day yeah that's why
you're wearing it yeah
it don't look like Harley would take a
very good gag
real talk that was my friend she was
like my massage therapist she was um
who's the winner so yo the one with the
pink with the Rings in the bottom right
she's the hottest one by far or the
other
it's the perfect size rampage that night
at least three white girls grabbed my
dick that night
no no absolutely not sure you need to
there I didn't know what it looked like
they had the printout now
who wins this I wasn't a FedEx it looks
like that lights out laying one no I
know lights out laying on the fights
I swear say it again and again fat ass
all the time well Cowboy can do that but
she won no others introduced him I think
I could beat cowboy in the MMA fight
I'll whip your [ __ ] Cowboy right
now Cowboy right now
Uber cowboy
look at Uber Cowboy Super Cowboy hey
give me give me three weeks off this
I'll be Cowboy have you seen have you
seen when uh Hulk grabs Loki and just
[ __ ] gang gang gang that's how I do
last 15 minutes ago to this part yeah
right
hey man you put me and cowboy and MMA
um [ __ ] octagon or cage yeah or your
bed yeah I was about to say you're bad
too I bet it's [ __ ] big I just want
to say there's something so hot boy
these girls are willingly subjecting
themselves to something that's stupid
yeah
it's very hard yeah
in a boxing ring after the fight I mean
it's just that's just so trashy and so
hot to me bro that they don't have
anything better as like an opportunity
that they could have been doing you
can't objectify today they're like one
of the most thoughtful humans I mean you
always say sentences that are just like
great thanks
all the time this guy did yeah
absolutely don't objectify them they
want you to guess what you're absolutely
right here don't rejectify them today
objectify themselves first
um well I would say that that's
definitely what's going on wait so that
was that was the main event that was
amazing it's over fellas that's it and
then we're doing it this thing's gonna
take two long but we can stay and watch
kids
so now we're doing now we're doing later
it's kind of hard I'm not gonna lie
she's kind of hot
I [ __ ] with her sure yeah I'll smash
that right there I smashed that yeah
your wife ain't watching four hours dude
longer than serious longer than any
fight that's happened tonight there's
more of a girl yeah I'm telling you I'm
the only fans manager I can make the
most money with her yes for sure hey can
I ask you something can I ask you
something last question then we got cut
off for it it goes too long I have this
friend okay she's scared about own
things but she want to start she's not
bad looking can I send her your way and
you can get her going I'll give her a
review
like but you can't [ __ ] her because I'm
probably gonna have to [ __ ] oh yeah you
don't want that you don't want to [ __ ]
it we can't say wow
you just don't want your age Jesus don't
let her hear you saying she's not
battling you can't [ __ ] it though you
can't [ __ ] her though tell us who it is
I'll take you off camera you can't [ __ ]
it though but can you help you make
money he does the eye for the he's like
Suge Knight
you ready you know the winner is come on
that one
yeah
she's the hardest one hell yeah everyone
can see that somebody comment the Hat
come with the adults
but she got no tattoos but then she got
these stupid ass tattoos on her feet
of women I'm just saying no tattoos is
very valuable all right
I'm 22 I'm B shop love you guys thank
you so much
thanks for having me Barstool shout out
to you guys love you much love